I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hi, Angela. Hello, lady.
我是珍娜·菲舍尔，我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》，并且是最好的朋友。现在我们为你带来了专属的《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士们。嗨，安吉拉。你好，女士。
We're not in the studio together today, are we? We're not. But you look like you're in a fancy studio. I am in the fancy New York offices of Stitcher. Get out! You're in New York City! Yeah! And guess what, lady?
我们今天没有一起在录音室里，对吧？是的，没有。但你看上去像是在一个很高级的录音室里。我的确在 Stitcher 位于纽约的高级办公室里。少来！你在纽约市！耶！你猜怎么着，女士？
What? Guess what? What? Our picture is on the wall here. In New York? Yes! In the New York offices! They have our Office Ladies picture on the wall.
什么？猜猜看什么？什么？我们的照片就挂这儿的墙上。在纽约？是的！在纽约办公室里！他们把我们的“办公室女士”照片挂在墙上。
I took a picture with it. Ah! That's so cool! I know. We have photos in two cities. Two cities? That's the big time! We're Bicostal!
我和它合影了。啊！太酷了！我知道。我们在两座城市都有照片。两座城市？这可是大制作了！我们是横跨两岸的！
We are! Wait a second! Wait a second! Right now we're Bicostal. Office Ladies has gone Bicostal. That feels real boss, lady. It does. I like it.
我们就是！等一下！等一下！现在我们是横跨两岸的了。“办公室女士”已经走向跨海岸了。这感觉真有老大的范儿，女士。确实。我喜欢。
Me too. Well, since we're talking about being in offices, Jenna, guess who's back at Dunder Mifflin? Toby. Well, not everybody's happy about it. No! God! No!
我也一样。好吧，既然我们在谈论办公室，珍娜，你猜谁回邓德·米夫林了？托比。好吧，可不是每个人都为此高兴。不！天哪！不！
God! Please, no! No! No! No! No! No! That's right.
天哪！求你了，不！不！不！不！不！不！没错。
Today we are talking about frame Toby! It is season 5, episode 9. It is written by Mindy Kayling and directed by Jason Reitmen. That's a good duo. I'm gonna give you a summary. I was hoping you would. Michael reacts poorly to the revelation that Toby is back at the scrambranch. I like the use of the word poorly.
今天我们要聊的是《陷害托比》！这是第五季第九集。由敏迪·卡灵编剧，杰森·雷特曼执导。真是个不错的黄金搭档。我来给你做个总结。我正希望你这么做呢。迈克尔对托比回到分公司这一消息反应强烈。我喜欢“强烈”这个词。
I know, that's an understatement. So he and Dwight hatch a plan to frame Toby for drugs that Michael has purchased from the two Vance refrigeration employees, Geno and Leo. Pam is incensed by a mess that is left in the microwave by one of her co-workers, We Don't Know Who. She leaves a pointed note, which elicits mixed reactions from the fellow employees. Meanwhile, Ryan breaks up with Kelly, and Jim surprises Pam with the news that he bought his parents' house for them.
我知道，这都算轻描淡写了。于是他和德怀特密谋，打算把迈克尔从两个范斯冷气公司员工杰诺和里奥那里买来的毒品栽赃给托比。帕姆对同事（我们不知道是谁）留在微波炉里的烂摊子感到愤怒。她留下了一张尖锐的便条，这在同事中引起了复杂的反应。与此同时，瑞安和凯利分手了，而吉姆则给了帕姆一个惊喜，告诉她他把父母的房子买下来了。
That's a lot. It's a lot. These headphones are tight. The headphones are tight in New York. I fixed them. Do you want a different pair? No, I fixed them. You guys, that was Jared in New York.
这信息量真大。确实很大。这耳机真紧。纽约的耳机太紧了。我已经调好了。你想要换一副吗？不用，我调好了。各位，那是纽约的杰瑞德。
Yeah. Jared is the Sam of New York. Yeah. Sam, say hi. Little Digit LA there in our loose headphones. Why? I think she likes them loose. I like a loose headphone.
对。杰瑞德就是纽约的萨姆。是的，萨姆，打个招呼吧。洛杉矶的小数字，戴着我们松垮的耳机。为什么？我想她喜欢松一点的。我喜欢松一点的耳机。
Oh, in that case, take that, Jared. Jared's all squeezing my brain with the headphones here in New York. Should we go into Fast Facts? I think we should. All right. Fast fact number one, you might remember, because we shared this earlier, that NBC ordered 28 episodes for season five. It was our longest season.
哦，那样的话，接招吧，杰瑞德。杰瑞德在纽约用耳机挤压我的大脑呢。我们该进入快速事实环节了吗？我想我们应该。好的。快速事实一号，你们可能还记得，因为我们之前分享过，全国广播公司为第五季订购了28集。这是我们最长的一季。
I remember, Jenna, when we wrapped season five, we all got sick. Oh, yeah. Like we all got the flu or something, because I remember the next week, like texting a few people, I'm like, I have a cold. Kate was like, yeah, me too. I think our bodies were just like, yeah. A standard network television season usually runs on television from September to May. We work from July to March, right, so that we can get the episodes ready.
珍娜，我记得当我们拍完第五季时，大家都生病了。哦，对。就像我们都得了流感什么的，因为我记得第二周，我还给几个人发短信，说我感冒了。凯特说，是啊，我也是。我觉得我们的身体当时就像是在说，够了。标准的美剧电视播出季通常是从9月到次年5月在电视上播出。我们从7月到次年3月工作，对吧，这样我们才能把剧集准备好。
And a standard television schedule is usually where you do three weeks on, one week off of filming. So usually a show will take one hiatus week a month, but the writers always continue to work for that week. That week off is meant so that the writers and the producer, they have a sort of catch-up week, because they're constantly writing, prepping, editing, delivering the episodes. They would have these episodes in multiple forms. They're like doing an outline for one, but they're writing another.
标准的电视剧制作进度通常是拍三周，休息一周。所以通常一个剧组一个月会休息一周，但编剧们在那周总是继续工作。休息的那一周是为了让编剧和制片人有一个补进周，因为他们一直在写作、筹备、剪辑、交付剧集。他们会同时拥有这些剧集的多种版本。他们可能在为一个写大纲，同时在写另一个。
They're punching up another one. They're doing post-editing on another one. They've got like five episodes going at once. We would just be like, what are we filming this week? Right. This year, with this crazy 28 episode season, Steve Carell also had a commitment to do a film. I think it was Get Smart, and he needed like a six to eight week break from the show in
他们还在润色另一个。他们还在对另一个进行后期剪辑。他们同时进行着大约五集。我们通常会问，我们这周拍哪一集？对。今年，由于这疯狂的28集拍摄季，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔还承诺去拍一部电影。我想那是《糊涂侦探》，他需要在7月到3月的拍摄日程中间请6到8周的假期去拍《糊涂侦探》。
the middle of that July to March filming schedule so he could film Get Smart. How did we ever do that? In order to do that, we had to film 19 episodes in a row. That's when we got sick. That's when we got sick. I just have a memory of a bunch of us getting a cold buck. That was it. Yeah.
我们当时是怎么做到的？为了做到这一点，我们必须连续拍摄19集。我们就是在那时候生病的。就是那时候生病的。我只记得我们一帮人都得了感冒。就是这样。对。
So, FrameToby was right in the middle of this crazy 19 episode schedule, and here's why I think this is significant. It's really crazy to me that they decided to bring Toby back in the middle of this 19 episode stretch because remember, he was now our showrunner because Greg was doing Parks and Rec. So, Paul Lieberstein is now showrunning and acting in an episode. Again, because they gave him that break, and now they're like, sorry, bud, you need to be Toby again.
所以，《陷害托比》正好在这疯狂的19集拍摄周期的正中间，这就是为什么我认为这很关键。我真的觉得很疯狂，他们决定在这19集的中间让托比回归，因为记住，他现在是我们的剧集运作人了，因为格雷格在做《公园与游憩》。所以，保罗·利伯斯坦现在既要运作剧集，还要在其中一集里演戏。还是那句话，因为他们给了他那个假期，现在他们又说，对不起，老兄，你得再次成为托比了。
You're back in the mix. So, I reached out to Jen Salada who was running the show with him, and I said, do you know why you did that? Did you just want Paul to never sleep? What was your plan there? And she said, she can't remember exactly the reasoning, but because Holly had left, they were either going to have to cast someone new or bring Toby back. And that dynamic between Toby and Michael was so beloved, she said as a fan of the show,
你又回到这群人当中了。所以我联系了和他一起运作这部剧的珍·萨拉达，我说，你知道你们为什么要这么做吗？你们只是想让保罗永远不睡觉吗？你们当时有什么计划？她说，她记不清具体的原因了，但因为霍利已经离开了，他们要么得选个新人，要么就把托比带回来。托比和迈克尔之间的那种化学反应太受欢迎了，她说作为这部剧的粉丝，
she wanted Toby to come back to that role. As a co-showrunner, she was freaked out at the idea of Paul having to wear both hats, but she said he did it so well. And Paul said he doesn't remember sleeping a lot, but also he enjoyed doing it, you know, he liked his time on set with us. Well, I love Toby coming back just because watching Michael spiral is delicious. This is one of my favorite episodes of the season for that reason, so thank you, Paul, for doing that.
她希望托比回到那个角色中。作为联合剧集运作人，她对保罗不得不双肩挑的想法感到恐慌，但她说他做得太棒了。保罗说他不记得自己睡过很多觉，但也挺享受这个过程的，你知道，他很喜欢和我们在一起拍戏的时光。好吧，我喜欢托比的回归，仅仅是因为看着迈克尔精神崩溃太美妙了。出于这个原因，这也是我本季最喜欢的剧集之一，所以谢谢你，保罗，谢谢你这么做。
For Paul, but thank you. My fast fact number two is a big thank you to James Carey because he gave us the shooting draft for frame Toby. Yes, James, this was so fun to watch it with the shooting draft. Jenna and I were texting each other and calling each other like, oh my God, that's not in. But this is, but did you see that? It was really fun. And this is a particularly amazing episode to have the script for because this microwave
为了保罗，但也谢谢你。我的快速事实二号是对詹姆斯·凯瑞的巨大感谢，因为他给我们提供了《陷害托比》的拍摄剧本。是的，詹姆斯，拿着拍摄剧本看这一集太有趣了。我和珍娜互相发短信、打电话说，哦天哪，那段没拍进去。但这段有，不过你看到了吗？真的很有趣。而且有剧本的这一集特别惊艳，因为这个微波炉
runner, the dirty microwave runner, it was much bigger in the original script. Yes, and it was full of Angela and Pam stuff. Yes, so we get to share about all that today. So thank you, James Carey. Thank you, James Carey. We are also going to have some great location details, thanks to Randy Cordray. He told me all about Jim and Pam's new house. And I have to share something that Randy said in his email to me when I reached out to him
支线，那个脏微波炉的支线，在原始剧本里要大得多。是的，里面全是关于安吉拉和帕姆的内容。是的，所以我们今天可以分享所有这些。所以谢谢你，詹姆斯·凯瑞。谢谢你，詹姆斯·凯瑞。多亏了兰迪·科德雷，我们还将获得一些非常棒的外景细节。他向我详细讲述了吉姆和帕姆的新房子。当我联系兰迪时，我必须分享一些他在电子邮件中对我说的话
about this episode. Are you ready? Okay. Yeah. He said, a particular delight of looking forward to your questions each week is that I get to revisit each episode to refresh my memory of what we collectively accomplished. Here's what his process is when I write him an email. Oh, he says, my process is to reread the shooting draft, watch the episode, watch any deleted
关于这一集。准备好了吗？好的。嗯。他说，每周期待你们的问题的一个特别的乐趣是，我可以重温每一集，来刷新我对我们共同成就的记忆。当我给他写电子邮件时，他的流程是这样的。哦，他说，我的流程是重读拍摄剧本，观看这一集，观看任何删减片段，并听取可能已经录制的任何评论音轨。
scenes and listen to any commentary that might have been recorded. Randy, this is what I do every week. This is what Chyn and I are doing. That's what I said. Oh my gosh. I said, you are an office lady. And Jenna, every time you email him a question now, I'm going to be like, don't ask him that. I don't want to send him down a rabbit hole.
兰迪，这就是我每周做的事情。这也是我和珍娜正在做的。我是这么说的。哦天哪。我说，你真是一个办公室女士。珍娜，以后每次你发邮件问他问题，我都要说，别问他那个。我可不想把他带进兔子洞里。
I know, but he really said he's really been liking it. And remember when our podcast for Weight Loss came out and Randy wrote us that night's email? He wrote us the most lovely email. Yeah. He was just like, ladies, you nailed it. You got every bit of information that could be known about how we did that engagement scene with the rain and the parking lot.
我知道，但他确实说他真的很喜欢。还记得我们的播客《减肥》出来的那天晚上兰迪给我们写信吗？他给我们写了一封最可爱的信。是的。他简直就像是，女士们，你们太棒了。关于我们在雨中和停车场的那场订婚戏是怎么拍的，你们把所有能知道的信息都挖掘出来了。
I'm so proud of you too. I know it was like we got an email from our dad. That's how I felt. Like dad thought we did a good job. I know. I want Randy's respect. I do too because I respect him. Look what he's doing.
我为你们俩感到骄傲。我知道，那种感觉就像我们收到了爸爸发来的邮件。我的感觉就是这样。就像爸爸觉得我们做得很好。我知道。我想赢得兰迪的尊重。我也想，因为我很尊重他。看看他在做什么。
Just off an email of questions. We got to have him on the show. He's got to come on. He's an office lady. We need to have Randy and James come on. Yes. Because they worked together. Okay.
仅凭一封包含问题的邮件。我们得请他上节目。他必须得来。他是个办公室女士。我们需要请兰迪和詹姆斯来。是的。因为他们一起共事过。好吧。
Future revisited everybody. Did you hear that, Randy and James? I guess that's my serious tone. What am I doing? Did you hear that? You're coming on the pod, fellas. I'm going to move us into fast fact number three. Okay.
未来重温，各位。你们听到了吗，兰迪和詹姆斯？我想这是我严肃的语气。我在干什么？你们听到了吗？伙计们，你们要上播客了。我要带大家进入快速事实三号。好的。
I think the world is going to be grateful for this fast fact because I was grateful for it. Oh no. Somebody did a deep dove. This is how to clean a microwave. Oh Lord. This episode's about dirty microwaves and I thought, how could we clean this microwave? This episode is about dirty microwaves.
我想全世界都会对这个快速事实心存感激，因为我就很感激。哦不。有人做了深入研究。这就是如何清理微波炉。哦天哪。这一集是关于脏微波炉的，我想，我们怎么才能把这个微波炉洗干净呢？这一集是关于脏微波炉的。
All right, Ainsley Bubicoe, our associate producer, helped me with this and I love it. Here is how to clean a real dirty microwave. Okay. All right. Get a microwave safe bowl, fill it with two cups of water and two tablespoons of vinegar. Now side note, if you'd like, you could add a drop of your favorite essential oil if you want. If you want to be fancy.
好吧，我们的副制片人艾恩斯利·布比科帮助了我，我太喜欢了。以下是如何清理一个真正脏的微波炉。好的。好的。找一个微波炉专用的碗，在里面装两杯水和两汤匙醋。顺便说一句，如果你愿意，如果你想的话，可以加入几滴你最喜欢的精油。如果你想讲究一点的话。
Yeah. You can clean your microwave fancy or regular. Okay. Now, turn the microwave on, obviously put the bowl in the microwave and then put it on high for five minutes. You want it to get real steamy in there. Okay. That's what she said.
是的。你可以把微波炉洗得很精致或很普通。好的。现在，打开微波炉，显然把碗放进微波炉里，然后开高火五分钟。你想让里面充满蒸汽。好的。正如她所说。
Mm-hmm. After it's done, don't open the microwave door for 15 minutes. Why? Because you'll burn yourself or something? No, because that makes all the baked on grime sort of soften. And then you can wipe it off? Yeah. That's step three.
嗯哼。结束后，不要打开微波炉门15分钟。为什么？因为你会烫伤自己还是怎么的？不，因为那样会让所有烤焦的污垢变软。然后你就能把它擦掉了？是的。那是第三步。
Wipe it off. Just wipe it out. Done. Your microwave is clean. Welcome. That's it. We can go to break. You can clean your microwave while you listen to some advertisements.
擦掉它。直接擦干净。搞定。你的微波炉干净了。不客气。就是这样。我们可以去休息了。你可以在听广告的同时清理你的微波炉。
Or if you're listening on Stitcher Premium, you won't have time to clean your microwave because it's ad-free. Oh. Well, let's take a break because Jinda just told me the bathrooms in New York are real far from where you're sitting. They are and you need a key. Oh. Yeah.
或者如果你在 Stitcher Premium 上收听，你就没有时间清理微波炉了，因为它是无广告的。哦。好吧，我们休息一下，因为珍娜刚刚告诉我，纽约的洗手间离你坐的地方真的很远。确实很远，而且你需要一把钥匙。哦。是的。
Well, in LA, it's a porta potty on the side of the road. So I'm going to go and I'm kidding. Sam is applauding. All right, guys. We'll be right back. We'll be right back. Well, we are back and everyone's real excited because there's brownies in the conference room.
而在洛杉矶，那只是路边的一个流动厕所。所以我要去……开玩笑的。萨姆在鼓掌。好了，各位。我们马上回来。我们马上回来。好吧，我们回来了，大家都非常兴奋，因为会议室里有布朗尼蛋糕。
Every time I worked in an office and someone brought in a baked good, it was a whole exciting moment. Heck yeah. We're not sure why there are brownies, but everyone's real happy about it. It's true. We had a fan question from Jessica L that says, why are there brownies in the conference room at the beginning of the episode? Was it someone's birthday?
每当我在办公室工作，有人带来烘焙食品时，都是一个令人兴奋的时刻。绝对的。我们不确定为什么会有布朗尼，但大家都为此高兴坏了。确实。我们有一个来自杰西卡·L的粉丝提问，上面写着，为什么在这一集开始时会议室里会有布朗尼？是谁的生日吗？
And then Jessica would like to know, did Angela bring the brownies? Because we've heard a lot of references to Angela's famous brownies. Yeah. Well, I looked at the script. Yeah. Because I had it. That's right. And she says, Phyllis is giving away brownies, but there is no further explanation as to
然后杰西卡想知道，是安吉拉带的布朗尼吗？因为我们听到了很多关于安吉拉著名的布朗尼的提及。是的。好吧，我看了剧本。是的。因为我有剧本。没错。而上面写着，菲利斯在分发布朗尼，但没有进一步解释
why. But it does make a note that Angela is not eating the brownies. Yeah. In the script, Pam is like, Angela, why aren't you having any? Yeah. Pam, a little bit of a sh** stir. Andy says, she's dieting. My baby's trying to fit into a child-size wedding gown for our big day.
为什么。但它确实记下了安吉拉没有吃布朗尼。是的。在剧本里，帕姆说，安吉拉，你怎么不吃一点？是的。帕姆，有点像个爱挑事的人。安迪说，她在减肥。我的宝贝正努力塞进儿童码的婚纱里，为了我们的盛大日子。
And Jim says, why? And why do those exist? Yeah. And then Angela says, it's from my pageant days. I was Miss Tiny Mid-Atlantic Bride when I was 10. What? Was Angela's childhood? I don't know.
然后吉姆说，为什么？而且为什么会有那种尺码？是的。然后安吉拉说，这是我选美时期的经历。我10岁时曾是微型大西洋中部新娘。什么？安吉拉的童年到底经历过什么？我不知道。
Seriously. And you guys, remember, this is a callback. Remember performance review season two, Angela had a talking head where she said, and I quote, I actually look forward to performance reviews. I did the Youth Beauty pageant circuit, and I enjoyed that quite a bit. I really enjoy being judged. I believe I hold up very well, even to severe scrutiny. Well, we know that you won Miss Tiny Mid-Atlantic Bride when you were 10.
说真的。而且你们知道，记住，这是一个前后呼应。还记得第二季的绩效评估吗，安吉拉有一个独白，她说，我引用一下，我其实很期待绩效评估。我参加过青年选美比赛，我挺喜欢那个的。我真的很享受被人评判。我相信我经得起考验，哪怕是面对最严苛的审视。好吧，我们知道你10岁时赢得了微型大西洋中部新娘。
And that's my wedding dress. There it is. I wonder how many more of these that you won. I wonder, were you a big winner in your mind as the character of Angela? Do you think she won quite often? Yes. I think that Angela Martin, like, peaked at 13. Okay.
那就是我的婚纱。就是这样。我想知道你还赢过多少这样的比赛。我想知道，作为安吉拉这个角色，在你心里你是一个大赢家吗？你觉得她赢得挺频繁的吗？是的。我认为安吉拉·马丁在13岁时就达到了人生巅峰。好的。
Like, she was it. She won all of, like, the young pageant, junior pageant, and then she retired. I see. Okay. Let us move on. While we're in the conference room, Kelly is going to take two brownies. One for Toby. Right.
就像，她就是最棒的。她赢得了所有年轻选美、初级选美的冠军，然后她就退役了。我明白了。好吧。让我们继续。当我们在会议室时，凯利拿了两个布朗尼。一个给托比。对。
Mm-hmm. And Michael kind of scoffs at this, but nobody else seems to think it's a joke. Yeah. He calls her a weirdo. He's like, whatever weirdo. I know. And Jim is like, Michael, Toby is back. And Michael's like, okay.
嗯哼。迈克尔对此有点冷嘲热讽，但其他人似乎不觉得这是个笑话。是的。他叫她怪胎。他就像是，随便啦，怪胎。我知道。吉姆则说，迈克尔，托比回来了。而迈克尔却说，好吧。
And so he walks back to the annex and no one's there, but then suddenly someone is there. And it is Toby. It is Toby. I want you guys to know at one minute, 23 seconds, as Michael turns to see Toby and he has that look of horror in his face, if you look at the wall behind him, you will see that there are three framed sort of things on the wall for Toby. There is an award for Toby Flindersen, a certificate of achievement, and a diploma from the California Coastal College.
于是他走回附楼，那里一个人也没有，但突然间有人了。那就是托比。就是托比。我想让你们知道，在1分钟23秒时，当迈克尔转身看到托比，脸上露出惊恐的表情时，如果你看他身后的墙，你会发现墙上有三个为托比装裱好的东西。有一个托比·弗林德森的奖状、一份成就证书，以及一张加利福尼亚海岸学院的毕业证。
So Jenna, he had been back long enough to hang up his framed items. And in the script, Toby had a talking head where he said this, I've been back for six days. I think I've even talked to him. I wish that stayed in. Me too. I wish so much it had stayed in. For my background catch folks, the California Coastal College, I don't think that's a thing.
所以珍娜，他回来得足够久，都已经把这些装裱好的东西挂上去了。而在剧本中，托比有一段独白，他是这么说的，我已经回来六天了。我想我甚至跟他说过话。我真希望这段能保留下来。我也是。我太希望它留下来了。对于寻找背景彩蛋的朋友们，加利福尼亚海岸学院，我觉得这地方不存在。
I Googled it, I couldn't find it. I did find the California Coast University, which is a private online university based in Santa Ana, California. Oh, there you go. My background people. Well, we got a lot of fan mail. People wanted to know if Michael's screaming no and all of that was improvised or if it was in the script.
我用谷歌搜过，没找到。我找到了加利福尼亚海岸大学，这是一所位于加利福尼亚州圣安娜的私立在线大学。哦，原来如此。我的背景彩蛋迷们。好吧，我们收到了很多粉丝来信。人们想知道迈克尔大喊“不”以及所有这些是即兴发挥还是剧本里写的。
In the script, it just says Michael turns and screams in all caps. Yeah. But that whole like, no, no, God, no, that was Steve. That was Steve's interpretation of that script note. And how funny was that? You guys, if you read that you scream, I think most of us would just be like, ah, right? Yes. But Steve made a meal out of that moment.
在剧本里，只写着迈克尔转身大叫，全是大写字母。是的。但那种“不，不，上帝，不”，那是史蒂夫的发挥。那是史蒂夫对那个剧本提示的演绎。那有多搞笑？各位，如果你读到剧本说你大叫，我想我们大多数人只会“啊”一声，对吧？是的。但史蒂夫把那一刻发挥到了极致。
In the best way. He's a comedy genius. Yes. You know, Screen Rant did a list of the top 15 pop culture references created by the office and the meme of Steve saying no is one of them. I don't doubt it. I have been online where I see people that I don't even know, like respond to other people with just Steve's face going, no, it's amazing.
以最棒的方式。他是个喜剧天才。是的。你知道吗，Screen Rant 网站评选了《办公室》创造的 15 大流行文化梗，史蒂夫说“不”的那个表情包就是其中之一。我对此毫不怀疑。我在网上看到过，我甚至都不认识的人，在回复别人时只用史蒂夫说“不”的脸，太神奇了。
Well the episode starts and Michael is spiraling. He's going to call David Wallace. He's watching Stupid Toby as he shows his stupid photos of Costa Rica to Phyllis. Yeah. He manages to get David on the phone by texting him 911. Call me. But you know what? Michael said he's learned that people will not return his calls unless he texts 911.
好了，剧集开始了，迈克尔情绪崩溃了。他要给大卫·华莱士打电话。他看着愚蠢的托比向菲利斯展示他那些关于哥斯达黎加的蠢照片。是的。他通过发短信“911，请给我回电”设法接通了大卫的电话。但你知道吗？迈克尔说他吸取了教训，除非他发“911”，否则人们是不会回他电话的。
And now everybody does because they think something horrible has happened. So I had a pager when I first got to LA. So did I. You had to because you didn't like really have cell phones. You had a pager and the only reason you had a pager was so that your agent could page you if you got an audition. And then you would have to go find a phone. You'd have to find a pay phone.
现在每个人都会回电，因为他们觉得发生了什么可怕的事情。所以当我刚到洛杉矶时，我有一个寻呼机。我也是。你必须得有，因为你当时真的没有手机。你有一个寻呼机，你拥有寻呼机的唯一原因是为了让你的经纪人在你得到试镜机会时呼叫你。然后你得去找一部电话。你得找个公用电话。
Call them back. I used to keep a Ziploc bag full of change in my car for two reasons. One for all of the metered parking that didn't accept credit cards, just coins. And two so that I could find a pay phone and call my agent back when my agent paged me, which was maybe twice a year. Oh yeah. I remember one time distinctly I was driving through Santa Monica with some friends and my pager went off and I almost swerved off the road.
回电话。我以前在车里放了一个装满零钱的自封袋，有两个原因。第一，为了所有不接受信用卡、只要硬币的计费停车位。第二，为了当我经纪人呼叫我时，我能找到一部公用电话给经纪人回电，这大概一年才有两次吧。哦对。我清楚地记得有一次我和几个朋友开车穿过圣莫尼卡，我的寻呼机响了，我差点把车开出路面。
So I was like, my career is happening. I've hit the big time. I've been paged. We were supposed to be going to the beach. I was like, no, we can't do that now. I have to find a pay phone. So we're all like driving the streets looking for a pay phone. I pulled over.
当时我就想，我的事业要腾飞了。我迎来了高光时刻。我被呼叫了。我们本来应该去海滩的。我就想，不，我们现在不能去了。我得找个公用电话。于是我们所有人都在街上开车寻找公用电话。我把车停在路边。
I ran up to the pay phone. I put my quarters in, called them, and they were like, all right, have you ever needed any kind of glasses? I'm like, what? No. And they're like, we have an audition for you for lens crafters. They would like people who wear glasses. I'm like, that's not me.
我跑向公用电话。我把硬币投进去，打过去，他们说，好吧，你曾经需要过任何眼镜吗？我说，什么？没有。然后他们说，我们有个光学眼镜店的试镜。他们想要戴眼镜的人。我说，那不是我。
All right. Bye. Yeah, that's pretty much it. But then I did have a boyfriend once who was not calling me back. Did you light up that pager? I sure did with a bunch of 911s. You know it. Did you really?
好吧。再见。是的，差不多就是这样。但后来我确实交往过一个男朋友，他有一次不回我电话。你点亮那个寻呼机了吗？我当然点了，发了一堆911。你懂的。你真的这么做了？
Oh yeah. Oh yeah. I did. Were you a psycho girlfriend? You know what? Were you cheating on me that night? Oh, so you knew. You knew.
哦，是的。哦，是的。我做了。你当时是个有心理疾病的女朋友吗？你知道吗？你那天晚上是不是对我不忠？哦，所以你知道。你都知道。
I knew it. We broke up after that. Oh man. Yeah. I wouldn't light up the pager. I'm sitting here calling you psycho. I wouldn't light up the pager, but I would drive over and hide out in a bush. That's so much more elaborate than texting 911.
我当时就知道了。之后我们就分手了。天哪。是的。我才不会去点亮寻呼机呢。我坐在这里叫你神经病。我才不会去点亮寻呼机，但我会开车过去躲在灌木丛里。这比发“911”短信复杂多了。
Here was my plan. I was like, I know he's cheating on me, so I'm going to light up that pager and make it buzz so that while whatever they're doing, the pagers just like, yeah. I'm just going to ruin their good time. He probably just turned it off. I guess I'm just going to jump out of a bush and be like, hey, what are you doing? Gotcha. Now I'm going to go home because I've got twigs in my hair and I'm embarrassed.
我的计划是这样的。我想，我知道他在对我不忠，所以我要点亮那个寻呼机让它震动，这样无论他们在干什么，寻呼机就会一直震个不停。我就是要把他们的好心情给毁了。他可能只是把它关机了。我想我大概只能从灌木丛里跳出来说，嘿，你们在干什么？抓到了吧。现在我要回家了，因为我头发上全是树枝，而且我很尴尬。
Is this a plotline for mom detectives? Should we set mom detectives in the past where all we have are pagers and bush hiding? Oh, bush hiding. Uh-oh. That could be something else. What's wrong with us? Can we call it bush hiders? No!
这是“妈妈侦探”的剧情线吗？我们应该把“妈妈侦探”设定在过去那个只有寻呼机和躲在灌木丛里的年代吗？哦，躲在灌木丛。噢。那可能会是别的东西。我们怎么了？我们可以叫它“灌木丛躲藏者”吗？不！
We can't. It doesn't even make any sense. It doesn't make any sense. You go pitch it. Hi, our show. It's called Bush Hiders. And if you don't want to buy it, you're a natural. Because this is gold. And they're like, what's it about? And we're like, it's two mom detectives.
我们不能。这根本说不通。这根本说不通。你去推销一下吧。嗨，我们的节目。它叫《灌木丛躲藏者》。如果你不想买单，那你就是个天然呆。因为这可是个金矿。然后他们会问，这是讲什么的？我们会说，这是两个妈妈侦探。
They're older women. And comfortable clothing. Yeah, we're not wearing any designer clothes. We want like 30 minute wardrobe sessions. It won't be fitted. And we want a lot of old tech that no one watching it will really understand. And we're going to hide in some bushes.
她们是年纪大一点的女性。穿着舒服的衣服。是的，我们不穿任何名牌服装。我们想要大约30分钟的服装试穿。不需要合身。而且我们希望有很多观众根本看不懂的老旧科技。我们还要躲在一些灌木丛里。
Yeah. Do you want it? Uh... Okay, where are we? We shouldn't have shared that on the air because someone's going to steal it. I guarantee you in two years you're going to turn on HBO Max and there's going to be two 20-year-olds
是的。你们想要吗？呃……好吧，我们这是在哪儿？我们不应该在节目里分享这个，因为会被人偷走的。我向你保证，两年后你打开 HBO Max，就会看到两个20多岁的年轻人
starring in a show called Bush Hiders. Mark my word. Mark my word. And they're going to be young hot detectives and designer clothes. That's how it works in this business. That's right. I'm not jaded. All right.
主演一部名为《灌木丛躲藏者》的剧。记住我的话。记住我的话。而且她们会是年轻性感的侦探，穿着名牌服装。这就是这个行业的运作方式。没错。我才没有被生活磨灭热情呢。好吧。
What's happening in New York? Who am I here? I don't know. You just took a big swig of coffee and you're like, that's how it works in the business. Well, listen, you know what? David Wallace tells Michael he's just going to have to deal with it. Yeah. And he couldn't believe that one of his employees had been back so long and he didn't know.
纽约那边在发生什么？我是谁？我不知道。你刚刚大口喝了一口咖啡，然后说，这就是这个行业的运作方式。好吧，听着，你知道吗？大卫·华莱士告诉迈克尔，他只能接受现实。是的。而且他简直不敢相信他的一名员工已经回来这么久了，而他却不知道。
And Dwight and Michael let him know that the annex is icky. It's icky back there. Yeah. And he really wants David to get rid of Toby and David says, I can't get rid of him without cause. And Michael says, he has cause. It's because I hate him.
德怀特和迈克尔让他知道附楼很恶心。后面那里太恶心了。是的。而且他真的很想让大卫赶走托比，而大卫说，我没有理由是不能开除他的。迈克尔说，他有理由。因为我恨他。
Because? It's not obviously cause. Well, they're going to find something. But Jenna, another issue is happening. Yeah. It's a day of drama in the office. Pam is preparing food in the kitchen and she discovers a mess in the microwave.
因为？这显然不是正当理由。好吧，他们会找到借口的。但是珍娜，另一个问题正在发生。是的。这是办公室里充满戏剧性的一天。帕姆正在厨房准备食物，她在微波炉里发现了一团糟。
Jenna? Yeah. Did you see what Pam was preparing? I know what Pam was preparing. Cher! This is maybe one of my most frequently asked questions outside of what was in the teapot note. Yes.
珍娜？嗯？你看到帕姆在准备什么了吗？我知道帕姆在准备什么。蛋清！这可能是我被问得最多的问题之一，除了茶壶纸条里写的是什么之外。是的。
People are like, what is Pam microwaving in the episode with the dirty microwave? Here are some guesses. We got mail. Here are what people are guessing that I was microwaving. Okay. Apple juice. A probiotic drink.
人们总是问，在有脏微波炉那一集里，帕姆在微波炉里热的是什么？这里有一些猜测。我们收到了邮件。以下是人们猜测我在微波炉里热的东西。好的。苹果汁。益生菌饮料。
Egg whites. Bone broth. Soup. Milk. Porridge. Jenna, you tell us. It's egg whites. It's egg whites, which I, by the way,
蛋清。骨汤。汤。牛奶。粥。珍娜，你来告诉我们。是蛋清。是蛋清，顺便说一句，
knowing my BFF in real life, thought was kind of fitting. Yeah. Because you can buy egg whites in these little cups and that's what she's doing. She's going to microwave herself some egg whites. A lot of people also asked what was in the microwave.
了解我现实生活中的死党后，我觉得这挺符合你的。是的。因为你可以在这些小杯子里买到蛋清，而她正在做的就是这个。她要给自己用微波炉热一些蛋清。很多人还问微波炉里装的是什么。
That is also in the script. And it just says like a saucy mess, basically. It says, Pam opens the microwave door to put in some egg whites, but the microwave is splattered all over with red sauce. Now we're in the break room
剧本里也有写。上面只写着类似一堆带酱汁的烂摊子。上面写着，帕姆打开微波炉门想放进一些蛋清，但微波炉里面到处都溅满了红酱。现在我们在休息室里
and what would we title this? Jim's exposed in the break room. Exposure in the break room. Andy, I guess, has peepers like a hawk and read Jim's email and found out that Jim is buying his parents' house
我们该怎么称呼这个？吉姆在休息室里曝光。休息室里的曝光。我猜安迪有着鹰一样的眼睛，他偷看了吉姆的电子邮件，发现吉姆给父母买下了房子
and hasn't told Pam. Or as Kevin puts it, the same house he used to pee the bed in. Phyllis thinks it's romantic. Until she asks Jim where it is, Jim says it's on Lyndon Ave. And Phyllis makes a face and then in the background you see me kind of roll my eyes
却没有告诉帕姆。或者正如凯文所说，就是他以前尿床的那栋房子。菲利斯觉得这很浪漫。直到她问吉姆房子在哪里，吉姆说在林登大街。菲利斯做了一个鬼脸，然后你在背景里看到我翻了个白眼
like, ooh. I looked up Lyndon Ave in Scranton. I couldn't find a Lyndon Ave. I found a Lyndon Street, but it's sort of like in the heart of the city. There's like shops and churches and definitely no quarry nearby. Hmm, interesting.
好像在说，哦。我查了一下斯克兰顿的林登大街。我没找到林登大街。我找到了一条林登街，但它有点像是市中心。那里有商店、教堂，绝对没有采石场。嗯，真有意思。
We got a lot of questions from, for example, Brittany Y and Jenner B. Whose house did they use for Jim's parents' house? Was the interior a set or was it the actual house that they used for the exterior? This is where Randy Cordray really came through
我们收到了很多问题，例如来自布里塔尼·Y和詹娜·B的提问。他们用谁的房子作为吉姆父母的房子？内部是搭景还是他们拍外景时用的那栋真实房子？这就是兰迪·柯德雷真正
for me, Ange. Bring it home, Randy. I remembered that it was two different houses. We used one for the interior and one for the exterior. And Randy said that our location manager, Kyle Alexander had found several choices
帮我大忙的时候了，安吉。搞定它，兰迪。我记得那是两栋不同的房子。我们一栋用来拍内景，一栋用来拍外景。兰迪说，我们的外景经理凯尔·亚历山大找到了几个选择，
and that Randy had really hoped that they could find a single residence that they could do both interior and exterior just because it would be so much easier to shoot at just one location. But it didn't work out that way. Randy said everything they looked at
兰迪本来真的很希望他们能找到一个单一的住宅，既能拍内景又能拍外景，仅仅是因为只在一个地方拍摄会容易得多。但事情并没有那样发展。兰迪说他们看过的所有房子，
either worked for the interior but not the exterior or vice versa. So, for the exterior we used an occupied home on Calvert Street in Van Nuys, California. But the interior was not suitable to shoot.
要么适合内景但不适合外景，反之亦然。所以，对于外景，我们使用了加利福尼亚州范奈司卡尔维特街上一栋有人居住的房子。但内景并不适合拍摄。
This was because it was absolutely adorable inside. And it needed to look a little janky. Yeah, it was so cute. And when we were shooting there they would let John and I step in to the house to kind of get our makeup refreshed and touched up
这是因为里面实在太可爱了。而它需要看起来稍微破旧一点。是的，里面太可爱了。当我们那儿拍摄时，他们会让约翰和我走进屋里去补妆和打理
but we would just stand right inside and then we would go back outside again. And that was it. And it was cute inside. Oh my god, it was so cute. It was decorated like oh, like an English professor's a home
但我们只是站在门口里面一点，然后我们就得走到外面去。就是这样。而且里面真的很可爱。哦天哪，太可爱了。里面装修得就像，哦，就像一个英国教授的家
like just cozy cozy literary bookshelves just beautiful kind of restored home inside. So great. I did something similar one time on this show called Haters Back Off.
那种温馨舒适的文学书架，里面是非常漂亮那种翻修过的房子。太棒了。我以前在这个叫《边缘歇斯底里》的节目上做过类似的事。
We filmed the exterior in one house here and another. And when we were filming the exterior it was cold and kind of misty raining and they let us step inside just the front room. Yeah, same. But we waited, right? Yeah.
我们这里的一栋房子里拍外景，另一栋拍别的。当我们拍外景时，天气很冷，还下着毛毛雨，他们让我们走到里面，就前厅。是的，一样。但我们只是等着，对吧？是的。
We didn't go throughout their house at all but we stepped in the front room and I was with Steve Little and we weren't really sure what to expect. We opened the door to step in and there was maybe 4,000 tiny dolls. What?
我们根本没有在他们家到处走动，但我们走进了前厅，我和史蒂夫·利特尔在一起，我们其实不知道会发生什么。我们打开门走进去，里面大概有4000个微型玩偶。什么？
Yes. What? There were dolls in cases all kinds of fancy dolls in every kind of case you could imagine cases on the wall, little case stand on the ground. They were everywhere.
是的。什么？里面到处都是玻璃柜里的玩偶，你能想象到的各种精致玩偶，墙上有柜子，地上有小展台。它们无处不在。
And Steve and I stood right on the other side of the door and we're like, okay, so somebody likes dolls. Oh my gosh, I would be like, run. I know. Run now.
我和史蒂夫就站在门另一边，心想，好吧，看来有人很喜欢娃娃。哦天哪，我要是遇到这情况，肯定拔腿就跑。我知道。马上跑。
It was like, okay, alright. If you have that many dolls there's a very good chance that one of them is going to come alive and try to kill you. I mean, if we've learned anything one of them is possessed. One of them is possessed
当时的感觉就像是，好吧，好吧。如果你有这么多娃娃，很有可能其中有一个会活过来并试图杀了你。我的意思是，如果我们学到了什么，那就是其中有一个被附身了。其中有一个被附身了，
and you know who's on the case? The mom detectives. The mom detectives. We got that covered. We got it covered. We'll hide in the bushes. We'll figure it out. That's right.
你知道谁在调查这案子吗？妈妈侦探。妈妈侦探。我们搞得定。我们能搞定。我们会躲在灌木丛里。我们会想办法的。没错。
So this house was so cute. What Michael Gallenberg did our set designer, he added a broken rain gutter to the outside. He changed the front door so that it would match the other location.
所以这栋房子太可爱了。我们的布景设计师迈克尔·盖伦伯格在外面加了一个破损的雨水管。他改了前门，好让它和另一个外景地匹配。
Okay. Where we go inside. And he also added that swinging screen door that bangs into the overhead awning. Oh, that was really funny. I know. And then they also asked the home
好的。也就是我们进去的那里。他还加了一个会撞到顶棚遮阳篷的弹簧纱门。哦，那个真的很好笑。我知道。然后他们还要求房主
owner to turn off their sprinklers for a week leading up to the shoot to make the grass look kind of dry and weather beaten. And they did. They kind of killed their lawn for us. Thank you. Now for the interior of Jim's
在拍摄前的一周关掉洒水器，好让草坪看起来干旱、饱经风霜。他们真的照做了。他们为了我们把草坪差不多弄死了。谢谢你们。现在说到吉姆父母房子的内景
parents house and for the garage scenes they found an unoccupied home on Allatt Avenue, which is also in Van Nuys. It was only a few blocks away from the other house. And for this one, they went in,
以及车库的戏份，他们找到了阿勒特大道上一栋没人住的房子，也在范奈司。离另一栋房子只有几个街区远。对于这个，他们走进去，
they added the shag carpeting, they added the wood paneling, they changed the front door. Like they bought a front door and they put it on both houses so it would match, you know. So he was able to go in and completely set design
加了长毛地毯，加了木质护墙板，换了前门。就像他们买了一扇前门，把它装在两栋房子上，这样就能匹配，你知道的。所以他能够进去，并完全重新布景
the interior of the home. Is it A-L-L-O-T? A-L-L-O-T-T. And you say it a lot or Allatt? Allatt. Allatt? Allatt.
房子的内景。那是 A-L-L-O-T 吗？A-L-L-O-T-T。你是念作“阿勒特”还是别的？阿勒特。阿勒特？阿勒特。
So from everything I said, the thing that we're going to discuss is the street name and how to pronounce it. Listen, I want you to know something. Whenever I think about like where I'm going to live, I think about the name of the street and having to tell it
所以在刚才我说的所有事情里，我们要讨论的居然是街道的名字以及怎么发音。听着，我想让你们知道一件事。每当我想象我要住在哪里时，我都会想到街道的名字，还得把它告诉
to like the pizza delivery guy. I live on Allatt. Allatt. A-L-L-O-T. No, not Allatt. Not Allatt. Allatt. I play it out in my head.
送披萨的小哥。我住在阿勒特。阿勒特。A-L-L-O-T。不，不是阿勒特。不是阿勒特。阿勒特。我在脑子里排练过。
You guys don't do that? Clearly you'd rather live on Calvert Street. Calvert. Yes. Much easier for you to get your pizza on Calvert. That's right. I'm not spelling that every single time. This is like how strongly I felt
你们不这样做吗？显然你更愿意住在卡尔维特街。卡尔维特。是的。你在卡尔维特叫外卖容易多了。没错。我才不会每次都去拼写这个。这就像我对
about pockets and women's clothing. This is your soapbox moment, Angela. Yeah. I can't tell you like how many times I've had to spell my street name out. It's annoying. I'm not going to say it. Don't need the creepers.
女装口袋的执念一样强烈。这是你的个人演说时刻，安吉拉。是的。我无法告诉你我有多少次不得不拼出我的街道名字。太烦人了。我才不说呢。不需要变态尾随者。
You don't want anyone in your bush. I don't want anyone. Well, I might want someone in my bush, but I... I think he already lives with you. I think... Oh, jeez, Louise. Oh, my gosh.
你不想让任何人进你的灌木丛。我不想让任何人……好吧，我可能确实想让某个人进我的灌木丛，但我……我想他已经跟你住在一起了。我觉得……哦，天哪，路易斯。哦，天哪。
I don't know what's happening to us today. I don't know. Should I go to New York more or less? I don't know. I don't know. Oh, my lord. All right. We had some more questions because Jim,
我不知道我们今天怎么了。我不知道。我是应该多去纽约还是少去？我不知道。我不知道。哦，天哪。好吧。我们还有更多问题，因为吉姆
during the stocking head, he's showing us his parents' house. And Sam Kay would like to know, please explain the clown picture in Jim's parents' house. Please explain. Yeah. In the script, it just says,
在独白时，他正在给我们看他父母的房子。萨姆·凯想知道，请解释一下吉姆父母家里的那幅小丑画。请解释一下。是的。在剧本里，只写着，
Jim examines a hideous painting of some clowns putting out a fire. He tries to pull it off with all his might. Nothing. Jim grimaces. Randy Cordray told me that that clown painting was provided. It was made original for us
吉姆端详着一幅丑陋的画，画上是一些小丑在灭火。他使出浑身解劲想把它扯下来。纹丝不动。吉姆做了一个痛苦的表情。兰迪·科德雷告诉我，那幅小丑画是特意提供的。那是菲尔·谢伊的手下艺术家专门为我们
by one of Phil Shea's go-to artists. He did not have the artist's name in his files. So we'd like to put it out there. If you are listening and you are the person who painted the clown painting, will you contact us on Office Ladies Pod? We want to know more. Mm-hmm.
原创制作的。他的档案里没有这位艺术家的名字。所以我们想把它公之于众。如果你正在听节目，而且你就是画那幅小丑画的人，请在“办公室女士播客”联系我们。我们想了解更多。嗯哼。
But Randy Cordray said that the artist actually provided them with multiple preliminary choices. And that Mindy, Greg, Paul and Jen all had to stand and look at multiple clown paintings. And that's the one they chose. That was their job that day? Yeah.
但兰迪·科德赖说，其实是那位艺术家为他们提供了多种初步选择。明迪、格雷格、保罗和简都不得不站在那里看着好几幅小丑画。这就是他们选的那幅。那是他们那天的任务吗？是的。
Pick the clown painting. That was your day? Mm-hmm. I had to pick a clown painting. So crazy. It cracked me up that it was on the wall like that and that he couldn't remove it, because I feel like that's such a dad move.
挑一幅小丑画。那就是你们的一天？嗯。我得去挑一幅小丑画。太疯狂了。最让我捧腹的是它就那样挂在墙上，而且他还拿不下来，因为我觉得这太有老爸的作风了。
You know, it's like that moment where your mom is like, that painting is always tilted. It's always tilted. And then your dad goes and super glues it to the wall because he's tired of it tilting. It just made me laugh. I want to know the story behind why they bolted it down. Yeah.
你知道，这就好像那种时刻，你妈妈会说，那幅画一直是歪的。它总是歪的。然后你爸爸就用强力胶把它粘在墙上，因为他厌倦了它总是歪着。这真的让我笑出声来。我很想知道他们为什么把它用螺栓固定在墙上的幕后故事。对啊。
What is the story there? There's a story. We don't know what it is exactly. We don't know. Well, now, guess what? Oscar and Andy discover a note on the microwave. It's a very shaming note. It is.
那背后的故事是什么？这里面有故事。我们不知道具体是什么。我们不知道。好吧，现在，你猜怎么着？奥斯卡和安迪在微波炉上发现了一张便条。这是一张充满羞辱意味的便条。确实是的。
They think that the note is worse than the mess. Angela likes the note. She does. Meredith thinks that the person who wrote the note is definitely rich and should get off their high horse. I love this moment with this note on the microwave. I do too. It's so relatable.
他们觉得这张便条比那一团糟还过分。安吉拉挺喜欢这张便条的。她确实喜欢。梅雷迪思则认为写便条的那个人绝对是个有钱人，应该别端着架子了。我很喜欢微波炉上出现便条的这个桥段。我也是。太有共鸣了。
If you have ever worked in an office, there is at least once in your time of working in that office a note stuck to something about something that people are like, eh. Yeah. And also the note where the person leaving the note has clearly reached their limit. Yeah.
如果你在办公室工作过，那么在你工作的期间，至少会遇到一次有便条贴在某个东西上，针对某种让大家觉得“呃”的事情。是的。而且这种便条通常表现出写便条的人已经明显忍无可忍了。是的。
Yeah. They can't take it anymore. No, the note is masking a deep like river of anger. They're just pissed. Well, I think this is such a fun moment because we get to see Pam and Angela in agreement about something. I think Pam starts to doubt her note a little bit
对。他们再也受不了了。不，这便条掩盖了一场愤怒的深渊。他们只是被气疯了。我觉得这个桥段太有趣了，因为我们看到帕姆和安吉拉对某件事达成了一致。我觉得帕姆开始对自己的便条产生了一点怀疑，
when she realizes that Angela is on her side. Do you think? Yeah, I do. Well, the cool thing is that this moment at the microwave would have continued. In the script, there are two talking heads here, one from Pam and one from Angela. And lady, I thought we could read them.
当她意识到安吉拉和她站在同一边时。你觉得呢？对，我是这么想的。不过，最酷的是，微波炉前的这个桥段本可以继续下去。剧本里这里有两个单人访谈，一个来自帕姆，另一个来自安吉拉。我觉得我们可以读一下，伙计。
I did too. And they really further the story. It's so fun. Okay. Here was Pam's talking head from the script. She's holding up the note. This is the front of the note. And then it says Pam holds up a memo.
我也是这么想的。它们确实推进了剧情。太有趣了。好的。这是剧本中帕姆的单人访谈。她举着便条。这是便条的正面。然后剧本写道，帕姆举起一张备忘录。
This is the front of my latest office memorandum. This can only lead anyone to believe that I wrote the note, which I did. And then immediately it would cut to Angela's talking head. And this was what was in the script. Everyone keeps asking if I wrote the note on the microwave. It was so perfectly worded and a little bit snotty. I wish I had written it.
这是我最新办公室备忘录的正面。这只会让人以为是我写的便条，事实也确实如此。然后画面会立刻切到安吉拉的单人访谈。剧本里的内容是这样的。每个人都在问我是不是写了微波炉上那张便条的人。它措辞太完美了，还有点刻薄。我真希望是我写的。
Now, there were even more candy bag talking heads, which we'd filmed as well. And they ended up in deleted scenes. But these are the two that were in the script. Yes. And you guys, what cracks me up as well. I don't know if you noticed this. Not only are Pam and Angela kind of oddly
当时甚至还有更多关于糖果袋的单人访谈，我们也拍了。最后它们都成了删减片段。但这是剧本里仅有的两个。是的。而且大家伙儿，最让我喷饭的是。不知道你们有没有注意到这一点。不仅帕姆和安吉拉在这个争论中
on the same side of this argument. Did you notice, Jenna, that they're dressed alike? Yes. I noticed that Pam is doing that thing that Angela always does where she wears like a weird short sleeve sweater over a blouse. They both have V-neck short sleeve sweaters over short sleeve blouses. Angela's is like brown on brown and Pam's is black over purple. But what is this short sleeve sweater?
处在奇妙的同一阵线。詹娜，你注意到她们穿得像吗？注意到了。我发现帕姆在做那个安吉拉总是做的小动作，就是在一件衬衫外面套一件奇怪的短袖毛衣。她们俩都在短袖衬衫外面穿了V领短袖毛衣。安吉拉的是棕色配棕色，而帕姆的是黑色配紫色。但这种短袖毛衣到底是什么鬼？
I have to believe that was a genius wardrobe choice by Alicia Raycraft. I think so. Because that is funny. I screen grabbed them, I'm going to put them on side by side in stories. Well, we got a fan question from Maddie and Laura. They asked, in the episode, both Pam and Angela agree that the note on the microwave was acceptable and correct. Where do you guys stand in real life as Jenna and Angela?
我不得不相信那是艾丽西亚·雷克拉夫天才般的服装搭配选择。我也这么觉得。因为太搞笑了。我截了图，打算在快拍里把它们并排放在一起。对了，我们收到了来自玛蒂和劳拉的粉丝提问。他们问，在这一集中，帕姆和安吉拉都认为微波炉上的便条是可以接受的而且是正确的。作为詹娜和安吉拉，你们在现实生活中持什么立场？
Note or no note? You go. You go first. You go. Why are you making me go first? Oh, I'll tell you what. I'm probably a no note. I'll just sort of like stew and resent you forever.
贴便条还是不贴便条？你先说。你先来。你先。为什么非要让我先？好吧，我跟你说。我大概是不贴便条的那种人。我只会生闷气，然后永远怨恨你。
I'm probably a no note. But here is my reaction to the note. When I see the note, I'm like, you know what? You needed that whoever you are out in the world. You needed to get it out. So I'm okay with it. One time, Jenna, I'll never forget this. I was in high school and I had finally gotten my driver's license
我大概是不贴便条的。但这是我对这张便条的反应：当我看到这张便条时，我的反应是，你知道吗？无论你是谁，在这个世界上你确实需要这个。你需要把它宣泄出来。所以我能接受。有一次，詹娜，我永远不会忘记这件事。我当时上高中，终于拿到了驾照，
and we went to the mall. You know, you're going to go to the mall. And I think, Jenna, because I was so excited I had my friends in the car with me. We're at the mall. I was a little distracted and maybe I didn't do the best parking job. Okay.
然后我们去了购物中心。你知道的，总会去购物中心的。而且我想，詹娜，因为我太兴奋了，车里还载着我的朋友们。我们在购物中心。我有点分心，可能车泊得不是最好。好吧。
And after our day of going to Claire's boutique and hitting up 579, maybe the candle store, we go back out to my car and there is a note. Wait. I'm so sorry. You bought candles as a teenager? It goes that far back for you? Yeah.
在我们逛完克莱尔精品店、去了579店、也许还去了蜡烛店之后，我们回到我的车旁，发现上面有一张便条。等等。我很抱歉。你作为一个青少年居然买蜡烛？你从那时候就开始这样了？对。
I love a candle. And the teenage Angela went to the mall and she went to the candle store. She loved Yankee candles, Jenna. Okay. I'm so sorry. Go on. You get to your car.
我超爱蜡烛。十几岁的安吉拉去了购物中心，她去了蜡烛店。她喜欢扬基蜡烛，詹娜。好吧。非常抱歉。你继续。你走到车前。
Yankee candles. It was right next to the Hallmark store. I could get myself a card, maybe a knick-knack. Go get a candle. I'm sorry. How old are you? You're like, you're 16 in this story. I've been a grandma my whole life.
扬基蜡烛。它就在霍尔马克礼品店旁边。我可以给自己买张卡片，也许还有个小饰品。去买支蜡烛。对不起。你多大？在这个故事里你才16岁吧。我一辈子都像个老奶奶。
Anyway, I walk back out to my car with my friends. This is my first outing in my car to the mall. Yeah. There's a note under my windshield wiper. What's it say? This is what it said. Hey, dickhead. Next time, leave me a can opener so I can get into my car.
不管怎样，我和朋友们走回我的车旁。这是我第一次开车去购物中心。对。我的挡风玻璃雨刷下压着一张便条。上面写的什么？上面是这样写的：嘿，混蛋。下次给我开罐器，好让我能进车里。
Sorry. I was like, what? I must have sandwiched the guy's car. I don't know. Oh, but you know what? I was like, he needed that. Whoever he or she was, they needed this. They needed to get it out.
对不起。当时我就想，什么？我肯定把那家伙的车给夹在中间了。我不知道。哦，不过你知道吗？当时我想：他需要这个。无论他是男是女，他们需要这个。他们需要把它发泄出来。
Okay. So basically where you stand on notes is you wouldn't write one yourself, but you don't have a big kind of reaction. You don't take them personally when they're out. You sort of like that person needed to get it out. Think about the time it takes to sit down and write a note or type it out and print it on a piece of colored paper like Pam did. She had two different colors.
好吧。所以你们对便条的基本立场是，你自己不会写，但你不会有太大的反应。当看到别人贴时，你也不会对号入座。你大概会觉得那个人需要把情绪宣泄出来。想想看，坐下来写一张便条，或者把它打印出来，像帕姆那样印在彩色纸上需要花多少时间。她用了两种不同的颜色。
She had black ink. She had red ink. It was on a yellow piece of paper. She clearly needed to be heard in this moment. Yeah. So I would just hear her. Would you clean the microwave if it was dirty? I probably would.
她用了黑墨水。她用了红墨水。它是写在一张黄色的纸上的。她在这个时刻显然需要发出自己的声音。是的。所以我愿意听听她的声音。如果微波炉脏了，你会去打扫吗？我可能会的。
Wow. I would probably just clean it because I mean, who needs, and then that's done. Wow. I would just clean it. If I go into the little kitchen here at Ear Wolf and there's like a mess around the sink and it's not my mess, I just wipe it up. Here's what I would do. Okay.
哇。我可能就会去打扫，因为我的意思是，谁需要……然后这事就解决了。哇。我就会去打扫。如果我走进厄尔沃尔夫的这个小厨房，水槽周围一团糟，而且又不是我弄脏的，我就会顺手把它擦干净。我会这么做。好吧。
You look very serious. That's why I'm like, okay. Well, I'm thinking about it in my head. I'm really trying to, you know, ask myself, who am I? What would I do? I'm a problem solver, right? Yeah. So I kept going in the kitchen and they're kept being a dirty microwave.
你看起来非常严肃。这就是为什么我会觉得，好吧。嗯，我正在脑子里琢磨呢。我真的在试图，你知道的，问问我自己：我是谁？我会怎么做？我是个能解决问题的人，对吧？是的。所以我一直去厨房，结果发现微波炉总是不干净。
And there was no system in place for who cleans it. I would want to create that system or create that rule. 100%. Jenna, you would make a chore wheel. Yes. And we would all like on Mondays, I would be in charge of cleaning the office sink. Yes. Or it's Monday, microwave day.
而且也没有建立起轮流打扫的制度。我会想要建立那个制度或者定下规矩。百分之百。詹娜，你一定会做个值日转盘。是的。然后我们都会，比如星期一，由我负责打扫办公室水槽。是的。或者今天是星期一，微波炉日。
We'd give it a fun name. And that's the cleaning day and it would rotate around. And you know, part of that would be the cleaner you keep the microwave, the less work on the day you have to clean it. So it'll incentivize us all to keep a cleaner microwave because no one's going to want to clean it on their clean day. I like that very much about you. You're solution based.
我们会给它起个有趣的名字。这就是大扫除日，而且会轮流来。你知道，其中的一部分好处是，你把微波炉保持得越干净，到你值日那天要干的活就越少。所以这会激励我们大家都保持微波炉的清洁，因为没人想在自己的值日那天去打扫它。我很喜欢你这一点。你是解决问题导向的。
I am. Well, in the script, the microwave storyline continues. There is now another note on top of Pam's original note. And it says this, hey, anonymous coward who left the note, be a man, spend less time writing notes and more time cleaning up the microwave. Yeah. And then it continues throughout the episode, there would have been more notes piling up on the microwave, not just on the microwave.
我是。好吧，在剧本中，微波炉的故事线还在继续。帕姆最初的便条上面现在又多了一张便条。上面写着：嘿，留下便条的匿名懦夫，做个男子汉，少花点时间写便条，多花点时间清理微波炉。对。然后剧情继续推进，整集中会有越来越多的便条堆积在微波炉上，不仅是在微波炉上。
They're on the cabinets. They ran out of space on the microwave. They're taping them to the cabinets around the microwave. There are so many notes that clearly people have written multiple notes because there's not even that many people in the office to weigh in on this, right? Right. So here's one of the notes. Hey, whoever was bashing the first note, grow up.
它们贴在橱柜上。微波炉上的地方用完了。他们把便条贴在微波炉周围的橱柜上。有这么多的便条，显然人们写了多张便条，因为办公室里甚至没有那么多人来对这件事发表意见，对吧？对。所以这是其中一张便条。嘿，不管是谁在批判第一张便条，成熟点吧。
The microwave is filthy and no one here is a maid. And then there's another one that says, you are all a bunch of idiots and privileged ass wipes who weren't raised right. If I find you, I'm going to knock your teeth out. That's got to be Meredith, right? Do you think it's Creed? I think it's Meredith. I mean, Meredith is the obvious choice, but I think we could find out that Creed wrote
微波炉脏得要命，这里可没有人是女佣。然后还有另一张写着：你们全是一群白痴和享有特权的混蛋，根本没被好好教养过。如果让我抓到你，我非打掉你的牙不可。那肯定是梅雷迪思写的，对吧？你觉得是克里德吗？我觉得是梅雷迪思。我的意思是，梅雷迪思是显而易见的选择，但我觉得我们可能会发现其实是克里德写的。
it. Lady, I think we should take a break because when we come back, Michael is about to serve up some high caliber acting. I mean, watch out, Kurt Russell. Yeah. Michael Scott's coming for you. He sure is. All right.
伙计，我觉得我们应该休息一下，因为等我们回来时，迈克尔就要展现一些高水准的演技了。我的意思是，当心了，库尔特·拉塞尔。对。迈克尔·斯科特冲你来了。他当然会。好啦。
We'll be right back. It's time for Michael to do his best. This is Michael's best. Michael approaches Toby's desk to welcome him back. He's asking questions about Costa Rica. Toby says it was amazing, but he came back because it was kind of hard to meet people. It was hot. But Michael can't stand it.
我们马上回来。是时候让迈克尔展现他最好的一面了。这就是迈克尔最好的一面。迈克尔走向托比的办公桌欢迎他回来。他问了一些关于哥斯达黎加的问题。托比说那里棒极了，但他回来是因为很难结识新朋友。天气很热。但迈克尔受不了。
He cannot stand this incredibly innocent small talk with Toby. No, he can't. He goes back to his office. He has this talking head where he's like, I tried. I tried. I tried to talk to Toby and be his friend, but it's like trying to be friends with an evil snail. I want to know who in the writer's room came up with evil snail because it's so funny.
他简直无法忍受与托比进行这种令人难以置信的天真无邪的闲聊。不，他受不了。他回到了办公室。他做了一个单人访谈，大致是说：我试过了。我试过了。我试图和托比谈谈并成为他的朋友，但这就像试图和一只邪恶的蜗牛交朋友。我很想知道编剧室里是谁想出了“邪恶的蜗牛”这个词，因为太搞笑了。
It's such a good description of Toby. It's such a good description. And then he goes on to say he feels like Nev Campbell and Scream 2. And he has this very funny talking head where he learned a lot, I guess, from the Scream movies. But Jenna, there was another talking head in the script. So the one you see with the Nev Campbell, that was not in the script. So that must have been an alternate talking head they handed him on the day.
对托比来说这是个绝妙的形容。真是个绝妙的形容。接着他继续说，他觉得自己就像《惊声尖叫2》里的内芙·坎贝尔。他做了一个非常搞笑的单人访谈，我想他从《惊声尖叫》系列电影里学到了很多东西。但詹娜，剧本里其实还有另一个单人访谈。所以你看到的那个关于内芙·坎贝尔的访谈，并不是剧本里的。那一定是在拍摄当天临时交给他的备用访谈。
In the script, this is Michael's talking head. It's almost the same right up until the evil snail. So evil snail was in the script. Yes, evil snail was a keeper. We've always had that. But this is how it changed in the script. The last four months without Toby have been absolute bliss. I fell in love with a beautiful blonde woman.
在剧本中，这是迈克尔的单人访谈。直到“邪恶的蜗牛”之前，几乎都一样。所以“邪恶的蜗牛”是保留下来的。我们一直都有这个。但剧本里是这样修改的：没有托比的过去四个月简直是绝对的人间仙境。我爱上了一个美丽的金发女郎。
I fell out of love. I tried scallops. The office was broken into. I became a father. I grew a goatee. The Olympics were a great success for China. And now that I've tasted freedom, I can never go back. I'm going to kill him.
我又不再爱她了。我尝了扇贝。办公室遭了窃。我当了爸爸。我留起了山羊胡。奥运会在中国取得了巨大成功。既然我已经尝到了自由的滋味，就再也回不去了。我要杀了他。
No, too far. But I will do something. No, too little. I will get rid of him. Oh, I like it. I love his breakdown of what all happened. And I love that he included he grew a goatee. Me too.
不，有点过分了。但我会做点什么的。不，这还不够。我要除掉他。哦，我喜欢这样。我喜欢他对自己经历的种种事情的总结。而且我喜欢他把“留了山羊胡”也算进去了。我也是。
It's true, in fact, that Michael is going to try to get rid of Toby. He is looking for fireable offenses. Dwight says there are two that he can find in this binder. Workplace violence or sexual harassment. So I guess Michael's first plan is to try to get Toby to sexually harass Pam. He goes up to Pam's desk, he hands Pam a note, and he says, go give this note to Toby. Don't read it.
事实上，迈克尔确实打算除掉托比。他在寻找可以开除对方的过错。德怀特说他在这本文件夹里能找到两个。职场暴力或性骚扰。所以我想迈克尔的第一个计划是试图让托比对帕姆进行性骚扰。他走到帕姆的桌前，递给帕姆一张便条，并说：把这张便条拿给托比。不要看。
Don't read it. Pam reads it. In the note, it's written as if it's from Pam, and it says, please hug and kiss me no matter how much I struggle. I'm too shy to confess my love to you. Can you imagine if Toby had read that note? His brain would have exploded. Yeah.
不要看。帕姆看了。便条上的语气写得好像是帕姆自己写的一样，上面写着：请紧紧拥抱和亲吻我，不管我怎么挣扎。我太害羞了，无法向你表白我的爱。你能想象如果托比读了那张便条会怎样吗？他的大脑会爆炸的。对。
Well, that doesn't work. Yeah. Pam's like, no, I'm not going back there. So now the new plan is to get Toby to beat up Michael. Yeah. So they march back to the annex and Michael's sort of confronting Toby and trying to sort of, you know, antagonize him to hit him. And Dwight's like, hit him.
好吧，这招行不通。是的。帕姆说：不，我才不回去呢。所以新计划是让托比痛揍迈克尔一顿。是的。于是他们气势汹汹地回到附楼，迈克尔开始挑衅托比，试图刺激他好让他动手打自己。德怀特在一旁煽风点火：打他。
And then Kelly jumps in so quickly. Hit him. I know. First of all, her and Ryan were making out. Oh, yeah. That they've stopped making out so that they can weigh in and therefore a fight. They're like, do it. Hit him.
然后凯莉立刻插话进来。打他。我知道。首先，她和瑞安本来在卿卿我我。哦，对。他们停下亲热来发表意见并促成一场打斗。他们喊着：上啊。打他。打他。
Hit him. Toby refuses. It's not working. None of these plans are working. So you know what they're going to have to do? They're going to have to go big. They're going to have to frame Toby for drugs, like on the shield. I love that Dwight said I've framed many animals.
托比拒绝了。这招没用。这些计划全都没用。所以你知道他们接下来得怎么做吗？他们得玩大的。他们得像《盾牌》里那样，栽赃托比吸毒。我喜欢德怀特说的那句：我栽赃过好多动物。
I framed a raccoon opening a Christmas gift. Like, oh Dwight. Well, Michael thinks it sounds mean, but sometimes the end justifies the mean. That's such a good line. It's such a good line. It's so smart. It's smart. Funny.
我曾栽赃过一只正在拆圣诞礼物的浣熊。真是的，德怀特。好吧，迈克尔觉得这听起来很卑鄙，但有时目的可以使手段合理化。这台词太棒了。这台词太棒了。太聪明了。很聪明。搞笑。
It reminds me of this gem. I'm not superstitious, but I'm a little bit. Stitious. Yes. That it's right in line with that. So yeah, Michael's going to go and hit up Leo and Gino over in Vance refrigeration for some drugs. They give him what they say is two pounds of weed and they want $500.
这让我想到了这句金句：我不是迷信，但我有点……迷信。是的，这简直跟那句异曲同工。所以，迈克尔要去万斯制冷公司找里奥和吉诺买点毒品。他们给了他据称是两磅的大麻，并且索要500美元。
Michael has $500 in his wallet. I thought the same thing. That's a lot of cash in your wallet. And for my background catch people, did you see the Lackawanna library card in Michael's wallet? Yes. When he opens his wallet, there's a Lackawanna County library card. Do you know what I found recently when I was cleaning out my closet? What?
迈克尔的钱包里刚好有500美元。我也是这么想的。钱包里揣着这么多现金。对于那些注意背景道具的观众，你们看到迈克尔钱包里的拉克万纳图书馆借书卡了吗？看到了。当他打开钱包时，里面有一张拉克万纳县图书馆的借书卡。你知道我最近清理衣柜时发现了什么吗？什么？
Pam's wallet. You did. And in it, there's a credit card that says Pam Beasley. There's all these cards they made for my wallet, my prop wallet. I'll take a picture. We'll put it in pod. Yeah. We have to put it in stories.
帕姆的钱包。真的吗。里面有一张写着帕姆·比斯利的信用卡。为了我的钱包道具，他们制作了所有这些卡片。我会拍张照片。我们会发到播客里。对。我们必须发到快拍里。
That's so fun. How crazy is that? They did that. That's how detailed Phil Shea was. Yep. If you had a prop wallet, it reflected your character. Although, is Michael going to the library and why? What's that for?
太有趣了。这有多疯狂？他们竟然做了这个。菲尔·谢伊就是这么注重细节。没错。如果你有一个钱包道具，它就完美反映了你的角色。不过，迈克尔为什么要去图书馆？那是用来干什么的？
I mean, I feel like Michael's probably had that library card for like 20 years in his wallet. Yeah. Maybe there was a time where he didn't have internet and he'd have to go to the library. Oh wait, we didn't have internet. I know. Maybe he used to go to the library to make copies because the copier in the office is crap.
我的意思是，我觉得迈克尔的钱包里大概已经放了那张图书馆卡有20年了。对。也许曾经有一段时间他没有互联网，不得不去图书馆。哦等等，我们那时候没有互联网。我知道。也许他以前去图书馆复印文件，因为办公室里的复印机烂透了。
We'll get to that next week. Yeah. And you know how when sometimes we're watching an episode or we're breaking down our document to prep to do the podcast, we'll get curious about something and we'll do a deep dive. Did you do one on something? I didn't. Our associate producer Ainsley. Ainsley, what'd you deep dive?
我们下周会聊到那个。对。而且你知道有时候我们在看一集节目，或者在为录制播客做准备而梳理我们的资料时，我们会对某些事情产生好奇，然后深入研究。你对什么做过深入研究吗？我没有。我们的副制作人艾恩斯利。艾恩斯利，你深入研究了什么？
This is what she wrote me. She said, according to a regrettable Google search, the price of one pound of recreational marijuana in Pennsylvania ranges from $1,900 to $2,550. We had to know. She was like, okay, they're selling Michael two pounds of weed for $500? Ainsley got curious, how much is a pound of weed in Pennsylvania? And now I looked and we shot this in September of 2008. So how much was it in 2008?
这是她写给我的。她说，根据一次令人遗憾的谷歌搜索，宾夕法尼亚州一磅娱乐用大麻的价格在1900美元到2550美元之间。我们必须弄清楚。她当时想：等等，他们以500美元的价格把两磅大麻卖给迈克尔？艾恩斯利很好奇，宾夕法尼亚州的一磅大麻到底多少钱？现在我查了一下，我们是在2008年9月拍摄这一集的。所以2008年的时候到底是多少钱呢？
I'm not sure, but today that's going to run you quite a bit of money. With today's prices, Michael got a deal because it would cost him close to $5,000 to get two pounds of weed today. I also want to say that's clearly not two pounds of anything in that baggie. No, it's green, but it's not two pounds. I mean, two pounds, I have two pounds of things all over my house, like two pound weights, two pound bag of flour. That's not two pounds of anything.
I'm not sure, but today that's going to run you quite a bit of money. With today's prices, Michael got a deal because it would cost him close to $5,000 to get two pounds of weed today. I also want to say that's clearly not two pounds of anything in that baggie. No, it's green, but it's not two pounds. I mean, two pounds, I have two pounds of things all over my house, like two pound weights, two pound bag of flour. That's not two pounds of anything.|||我不太确定，但以今天的物价来看，那得花一大笔钱。按现在的市价，迈克尔算是捡了个大便宜，因为今天要买两磅大麻得花将近5,000美元。我还想说，那个小袋子里装的绝对不是两磅任何东西。不，它是绿色的，但绝对不到两磅。我是说，两磅——我家里到处都是两磅重的东西，比如两磅重的哑铃、两磅重的面粉袋。那根本不是两磅重的东西。
It's not. I've had a two pound bag of spinach in my house before. It's much bigger than that. It takes up the whole crisper drawer. You're very passionate about painting a very clear picture of what two pounds is. I mean, it's so glaringly obvious that that's not two pounds. There are so many signs that Michael is missing. Don't get Jenna started.
It's not. I've had a two pound bag of spinach in my house before. It's much bigger than that. It takes up the whole crisper drawer. You're very passionate about painting a very clear picture of what two pounds is. I mean, it's so glaringly obvious that that's not two pounds. There are so many signs that Michael is missing. Don't get Jenna started.|||根本不是。我以前在家买过两磅装的菠菜。比那个大得多。能占满整个果蔬保鲜抽屉。你对具体描绘两磅到底有多大充满热情。我是说，那绝对不是两磅，明摆着的事。迈克尔漏掉了那么多迹象。可别让珍娜打开话匣子。
Don't get me started on what two pounds of something is. I'll tell you about my two pounds of spinach. I just ordered two pounds of Epsom salts and that was a large package as well. What are you making? Warm soothing bath. Well listen, we're about to find out that Pam has an ally in this whole microwave business. Does she? She has Ryan, who's pretending to be an ally and he's laying it on thick and I love it.
Don't get me started on what two pounds of something is. I'll tell you about my two pounds of spinach. I just ordered two pounds of Epsom salts and that was a large package as well. What are you making? Warm soothing bath. Well listen, we're about to find out that Pam has an ally in this whole microwave business. Does she? She has Ryan, who's pretending to be an ally and he's laying it on thick and I love it.|||别让我开始细数两磅的东西到底长什么样。我来跟你们讲讲我的两磅菠菜。我刚订了两磅泻盐，那也是好大一包呢。你在做什么？温暖舒缓的泡澡。听着，我们马上就会发现，在微波炉这件事上，帕姆其实有个同盟。是吗？她有瑞恩，他假装是她的同盟，而且装得特别卖力，我可太喜欢了。
Yeah, he says I'm totally on your side. But the truth is, he went to make a cup of noodles and the microwave is still a mess. And he wants her to clean it up. And she delivers some real Pam sass. Hey Pam, I just want to let you know I'm totally on your side with the whole microwave situation. Thank you. I was just back there to make some cup of soup, the thing is still a huge mess. I know, can you believe it?
Yeah, he says I'm totally on your side. But the truth is, he went to make a cup of noodles and the microwave is still a mess. And he wants her to clean it up. And she delivers some real Pam sass. Hey Pam, I just want to let you know I'm totally on your side with the whole microwave situation. Thank you. I was just back there to make some cup of soup, the thing is still a huge mess. I know, can you believe it?|||对，他说我完全站在你这边。但事实是，他去泡了碗面，结果微波炉还是一团糟。而且他想让帕姆去收拾。接着她展现了帕姆式的经典毒舌。嘿，帕姆，我只想让你知道，关于微波炉这事我绝对站你这边。谢谢。我刚刚去后面冲了杯汤，那玩意儿还是乱得一塌糊涂。我知道，你能信吗？
Yeah, it's crazy. But I guess the thing is at some point, notes are no notes. Someone's going to have to just get in there and clean it up. I guess that's why we have a temp, huh? Oh no, trust me, I would just make it worse. How would wiping it with a paper towel make it worse? I would find a way. You've seen things clean before though, right?
Yeah, it's crazy. But I guess the thing is at some point, notes are no notes. Someone's going to have to just get in there and clean it up. I guess that's why we have a temp, huh? Oh no, trust me, I would just make it worse. How would wiping it with a paper towel make it worse? I would find a way. You've seen things clean before though, right?|||对，太疯狂了。但我想关键在于，不管有没有便签，总得有人亲自去把它清理干净。我想这就是为什么我们有个临时工，对吧？哦不，相信我，我只会越帮越忙。用纸巾擦一下怎么会越帮越忙？我总能找到办法的。不过你以前总见过干净的东西吧？
Hey Pam, I am hopeless at that stuff. I mean, that's some good Pam sass. That was all scripted. I know it sounds like Jenna sass. It was scripted. I just brought myself to it. You brought some real truth to it. I did.
Hey Pam, I am hopeless at that stuff. I mean, that's some good Pam sass. That was all scripted. I know it sounds like Jenna sass. It was scripted. I just brought myself to it. You brought some real truth to it. I did.|||嘿，帕姆，我对那种事一窍不通。我是说，这真是帕姆式的经典毒舌。那全都是剧本写的。我知道听起来很像珍娜的日常毒舌。那是剧本写的。我只是把它演活了。你给它注入了真实的灵魂。没错。
Well, Ange, we got a lot of fan questions asking who did clean the microwave? Because this never gets wrapped up. We never find out. Did it get clean? Who cleaned it? This would have wrapped up, it's in the script and we filmed a big scene that would have explained all of it. It was a fun scene too.
Well, Ange, we got a lot of fan questions asking who did clean the microwave? Because this never gets wrapped up. We never find out. Did it get clean? Who cleaned it? This would have wrapped up, it's in the script and we filmed a big scene that would have explained all of it. It was a fun scene too.|||安琪，我们收到了很多粉丝的提问，问究竟是谁清理了微波炉？因为这件事从来没有交代清楚。我们一直没找到答案。它到底变干净了吗？谁清理的？本来是可以交代的，剧本里写了，而且我们还拍了一场大戏来解释这一切。那也是个很有趣的场景。
It was and it has a great Pam Angela moment at the top. Yeah, so it starts with Angela, she's storming in from the kitchen, she's super ticked off and she's holding up a note, someone has drawn a penis on the note and she confronts Pam. I know. She thinks Pam drew the penis. Why does she always blame Pam for this kind of stuff? I don't know.
It was and it has a great Pam Angela moment at the top. Yeah, so it starts with Angela, she's storming in from the kitchen, she's super ticked off and she's holding up a note, someone has drawn a penis on the note and she confronts Pam. I know. She thinks Pam drew the penis. Why does she always blame Pam for this kind of stuff? I don't know.|||确实是的，开头还有一个非常精彩的帕姆和安琪拉的对手戏。对，事情是这样的，安琪拉气冲冲地从厨房闯进来，超级生气，手里举着一张便签，上面有人画了个男性生殖器，她去找帕姆对质。我知道。她以为是帕姆画的。为什么她老是把这种事怪到帕姆头上？我不知道。
Here's how it went. Pervert. Ange, well, I didn't do that. So is this what they taught you at your fancy art school? Why would I draw a penis on my own note? Why do you wear bright colors for attention, Pam? Everyone, I have an announcement to make. I'm the person who put the first note on the microwave.
Here's how it went. Pervert. Ange, well, I didn't do that. So is this what they taught you at your fancy art school? Why would I draw a penis on my own note? Why do you wear bright colors for attention, Pam? Everyone, I have an announcement to make. I'm the person who put the first note on the microwave.|||当时的情形是这样的。老变态。安琪，我可没干这事。所以这就是你在你那所高级艺术学校学到的东西？我为什么要在自己的便签上画个那玩意儿？帕姆，你为什么穿那么艳丽的颜色来博取关注？大家注意，我有件事要宣布。我就是那个在微波炉上贴第一张便签的人。
Yeah, Pam comes clean and I remember shooting this because Pam kind of goes on to take charge of the room after she admits that she wrote the note. She's like, and I guess I just have to say, what's so wrong about the note? Why is everyone so offended by this note? Shouldn't you be more offended by a consistently dirty microwave? She gets on her soapbox. It's Pam's soapbox. And you guys, as an actor, when we got to have a moment where we commanded the whole
Yeah, Pam comes clean and I remember shooting this because Pam kind of goes on to take charge of the room after she admits that she wrote the note. She's like, and I guess I just have to say, what's so wrong about the note? Why is everyone so offended by this note? Shouldn't you be more offended by a consistently dirty microwave? She gets on her soapbox. It's Pam's soapbox. And you guys, as an actor, when we got to have a moment where we commanded the whole|||对，帕姆坦白了，我还记得拍摄这一幕时的情景，因为帕姆承认便签是她写的之后，她就顺势掌控了整个房间。她说，我想我不得不说，便签有什么错？为什么大家会被这张便签冒犯到？难道你们不应该对一个长期肮脏的微波炉感到更生气吗？她开始大放厥词。这就是帕姆的夸夸其谈。大家知道，作为演员，当我们迎来一个可以掌控全场的时刻时，
bullpen, it was exciting. And also we were kind of terrified. Oh, yeah. Because you're in charge of the pace of the scene. This only happened to me a handful of times when Angela makes a big announcement or something. But I remember Jenna watching you and you were so good in this moment because everyone is throwing you little curveballs, Oscar and Stanley and Kevin. They're all kind of sassing you.
bullpen, it was exciting. And also we were kind of terrified. Oh, yeah. Because you're in charge of the pace of the scene. This only happened to me a handful of times when Angela makes a big announcement or something. But I remember Jenna watching you and you were so good in this moment because everyone is throwing you little curveballs, Oscar and Stanley and Kevin. They're all kind of sassing you.|||办公区，那种感觉既让人兴奋。又让人有点害怕。哦，对的。因为你要掌控整个场景的节奏。这种事我只经历过寥寥几次，比如安琪拉发布什么重大声明的时候。但我记得珍娜看着你，你在这一幕里表现得太棒了，因为每个人都在给你抛出各种小难题，奥斯卡、斯坦利和凯文。他们都在对你冷嘲热讽。
And you know, the last time that I had a scene like this was back in Beach Games. When Pam is going to confront the whole group about her feelings and how they didn't come to her art show. But in this instance, people were interrupting me and they're coming at me and I got such a window into what Steve's every day was. Yeah. At one point, the group starts hazing Pam about being in New York. And Pam gives this speech that kind of takes Jim off guard.
And you know, the last time that I had a scene like this was back in Beach Games. When Pam is going to confront the whole group about her feelings and how they didn't come to her art show. But in this instance, people were interrupting me and they're coming at me and I got such a window into what Steve's every day was. Yeah. At one point, the group starts hazing Pam about being in New York. And Pam gives this speech that kind of takes Jim off guard.|||你知道，我上一次遇到这种戏份还是在《海滩游戏》那一集。当时帕姆要当众向所有人倾诉她的感受，以及他们为什么没有去看她的艺术展。但在这次的场景中，大家一直在打断我，冲我发难，这让我真切地体会到了史蒂夫日常面对的是什么样的工作状态。是的。有一会儿，大家开始拿帕姆在纽约的事捉弄她。接着帕姆发表了一番演讲，把吉姆弄得有点措手不及。
And I think we should hear it. Listen, New York, that might fly. Why? Because I went to New York for three months. That and the black sweater Manhattan. Okay. Yes. I went to New York, everybody.
And I think we should hear it. Listen, New York, that might fly. Why? Because I went to New York for three months. That and the black sweater Manhattan. Okay. Yes. I went to New York, everybody.|||我想我们应该听听这段。听着，在纽约，这也许行得通。为什么？因为我在纽约呆了三个月。就凭这个，还有黑色毛衣曼哈顿。好吧。没错。我去过纽约，各位。
I'm not going to apologize for it. I experienced more there in one week than I experienced here in three months. I love New York. You know, I especially love that people there cleaned up after themselves. Well, Jim has just heard her say all that. Yeah. And the camera is pushing in on his face and he's realizing at the end of today, he's going to tell her he bought them a house in Scranton.
I'm not going to apologize for it. I experienced more there in one week than I experienced here in three months. I love New York. You know, I especially love that people there cleaned up after themselves. Well, Jim has just heard her say all that. Yeah. And the camera is pushing in on his face and he's realizing at the end of today, he's going to tell her he bought them a house in Scranton.|||我才不会为此道歉呢。我在那儿一周经历的事情，比我在这是三个月经历的还要多。我爱纽约。你知道的，我尤其喜欢那里的人会自己收拾残局。吉姆刚听到她说了这些话。是的。镜头特写推向他的脸，他意识到今天结束时，他得告诉她自己在斯克兰顿给他们买了一栋房子。
She's not going back to New York anytime soon. This place she loves. I really wish this moment had made it into the show because I feel like it just sets up the stakes for Jim because he's doubting his decision from the very beginning. Did I do the right thing? Is she going to like this? I don't know. And I feel like he needed to hear this and I feel like the audience needed to hear it.
She's not going back to New York anytime soon. This place she loves. I really wish this moment had made it into the show because I feel like it just sets up the stakes for Jim because he's doubting his decision from the very beginning. Did I do the right thing? Is she going to like this? I don't know. And I feel like he needed to hear this and I feel like the audience needed to hear it.|||她短期内是不会回纽约了。这个她深爱的地方。我真的很希望这个情节当初能剪进正片里，因为我觉得这为吉姆铺垫了很高的赌注，因为他从一开始就在怀疑自己的决定。我做得对吗？她会喜欢这个吗？我不知道。我觉得他需要听到这些，我也觉得观众需要听到这些。
I do too. I think it's a shame that it got cut out. And you know, at the end of this whole scene, Pam says, fine, I'll go clean it. So it is Pam in the end who cleaned the microwave. Yes. In the script, the very last line of this big scene says this, Pam marches over to the kitchen and Stanley starts to slow clap. Oh yeah.
I do too. I think it's a shame that it got cut out. And you know, at the end of this whole scene, Pam says, fine, I'll go clean it. So it is Pam in the end who cleaned the microwave. Yes. In the script, the very last line of this big scene says this, Pam marches over to the kitchen and Stanley starts to slow clap. Oh yeah.|||我也这么觉得。被剪掉真是太可惜了。而且你知道，在这整场戏的结尾，帕姆说，好吧，我去清理。所以最后是帕姆清理了微波炉。是的。剧本里这场大戏的最后一台词是这样的：帕姆气势汹汹地走向厨房，斯坦利开始带头缓慢鼓掌。哦，对。
We had a slow clap that didn't make it. Oh yeah. That's right. Looking back that memory of me walking to Stanley's slow clap. So good. It's time for Michael to plant what he thinks is two pounds of marijuana in Toby's desk. And at the same time, Dwight is going to call the police and report that there is a drug dealer named Toby Flandersen on the premises.
We had a slow clap that didn't make it. Oh yeah. That's right. Looking back that memory of me walking to Stanley's slow clap. So good. It's time for Michael to plant what he thinks is two pounds of marijuana in Toby's desk. And at the same time, Dwight is going to call the police and report that there is a drug dealer named Toby Flandersen on the premises.|||我们本来拍了慢速鼓掌，但没能播出来。哦，对。没错了。回想起来，我走向斯坦利那慢速掌声的记忆。太棒了。接下来轮到迈克尔把自认为是的两磅大麻塞进托比的办公桌里了。与此同时，德怀特要报警，举报大楼里有个名叫托比·克兰德森的毒贩。
And when asked to give his name, Dwight says his name is Andy Bernard. Dwight is going to throw Andy under the bus any chance he gets. There was this deleted scene, Jenna, that for Michael to be able to have the time to go plant the drugs, they needed to get Toby away from his desk. So Dwight asked Toby to show him his photos from Costa Rica. Let's go to the conference room. I'll look at your photos. Toby is thrilled that someone wants to see his photos.
And when asked to give his name, Dwight says his name is Andy Bernard. Dwight is going to throw Andy under the bus any chance he gets. There was this deleted scene, Jenna, that for Michael to be able to have the time to go plant the drugs, they needed to get Toby away from his desk. So Dwight asked Toby to show him his photos from Costa Rica. Let's go to the conference room. I'll look at your photos. Toby is thrilled that someone wants to see his photos.|||当被问及姓名时，德怀特说他的名字叫安迪·伯纳德。德怀特只要有机会就会把安迪给出卖了。珍娜，有一个被删掉的场景是这样的：为了让迈克尔有时间去藏毒，他们需要把托比从座位上支开。于是德怀特让托比把他在哥斯达黎加拍的照片拿给他看。我们去会议室吧。我来看看你的照片。托比一听有人想看他的照片，高兴坏了。
And then Michael sneaks off to plant the drugs. But in true Michael fashion, he can't keep the secret. He has to share with someone that he might have just done something. This is what he said. I think it's really cool that you wanted to see my photos. What's this pink thing on that white oval? That's me. I was boogie boarding.
And then Michael sneaks off to plant the drugs. But in true Michael fashion, he can't keep the secret. He has to share with someone that he might have just done something. This is what he said. I think it's really cool that you wanted to see my photos. What's this pink thing on that white oval? That's me. I was boogie boarding.|||然后迈克尔偷偷溜去藏毒。但按迈克尔一贯的风格，他根本藏不住秘密。他非得找个人分享他刚刚可能干了件大事。他是这么说的。你居然想看我的照片，我觉得这太酷了。白色椭圆上那个粉红色的东西是什么？那是我。我在玩趴板冲浪。
Okay, let me try. Who took this picture? Did you make some friends? I hired a local kid to snap it. Tell me about this monkey. Uh, okay, I'm not, I am not a liberty to talk about it. Let's just say that I somethinged something in somebody's something. And if discovered, then someone will get something.
Okay, let me try. Who took this picture? Did you make some friends? I hired a local kid to snap it. Tell me about this monkey. Uh, okay, I'm not, I am not a liberty to talk about it. Let's just say that I somethinged something in somebody's something. And if discovered, then someone will get something.|||好吧，让我也来问问。谁拍的这张照片？你交到什么朋友了吗？我雇了个当地小孩帮我拍的。跟我讲讲这只猴子吧。呃，好吧，我，我不方便透露。这么说吧，我在某人的某处做了一些某种事。如果被发现了，那某人就会得到某种惩罚。
I may have said too much. He can't not say anything. He can't. Containment is not his strong suit. No. And then I have to say that scene with Dwight and Toby, to me, it sounded like Rainn Wilson improvising questions, trying to stump Paul Lieberstein. Jenna, you're not wrong.
I may have said too much. He can't not say anything. He can't. Containment is not his strong suit. No. And then I have to say that scene with Dwight and Toby, to me, it sounded like Rainn Wilson improvising questions, trying to stump Paul Lieberstein. Jenna, you're not wrong.|||我可能说得太多了。他就是管不住自己的嘴。他根本管不住。保守秘密可不是他的强项。没错。然后我得说，德怀特和托比的那场戏，在我听来，就像雷恩·威尔逊在即兴提问，试图把保罗·利贝尔斯坦难倒一样。珍娜，你没说错。
I'm looking at the script right now. The part with what's the red thing crawling on that oval, that was scripted. Okay. But the tell me about this monkey is not in the script. Okay. Also, what about that question? Who took these pictures? That's in the script.
I'm looking at the script right now. The part with what's the red thing crawling on that oval, that was scripted. Okay. But the tell me about this monkey is not in the script. Okay. Also, what about that question? Who took these pictures? That's in the script.|||我正看着剧本呢。关于“椭圆上爬着的那个红色的东西是什么”这部分，剧本里是有的。好吧。但“跟我讲讲这只猴子吧”这句不在剧本里。好的。还有那个问题，“谁拍的这些照片？”那是在剧本里的。
Oh, it is. Yeah. That's a funny line. The improv moment is the monkey. Okay. The police arrive and they are going to look into this possible narcotics situation. Pam doesn't know anything about it. Dwight's going to take charge.
Oh, it is. Yeah. That's a funny line. The improv moment is the monkey. Okay. The police arrive and they are going to look into this possible narcotics situation. Pam doesn't know anything about it. Dwight's going to take charge.|||哦，原来是这样。对。那是个很好笑的台词。即兴发挥的部分是猴子。好吧。警察来了，他们要调查这个潜在的毒品案。帕姆对此外一无所知。德怀特要掌控全局。
And then Michael starts freaking out. Yes. And then they realize it's a Ziploc of maybe like, what, a Caprese salad? Yeah. It looks like there's definitely some cheese in there and some salad dressing. Yeah. I'll have you know, the police officers were played by Patrick Fossett and Michael Heridy, and neither of them have been on Monk.
And then Michael starts freaking out. Yes. And then they realize it's a Ziploc of maybe like, what, a Caprese salad? Yeah. It looks like there's definitely some cheese in there and some salad dressing. Yeah. I'll have you know, the police officers were played by Patrick Fossett and Michael Heridy, and neither of them have been on Monk.|||然后迈克尔开始慌神了。是的。接着他们发现那袋密封袋里装的可能是，什么来着，卡布里沙拉？对。里面明显有些奶酪和沙拉酱。是的。顺便告诉大家，扮演警察的是帕特里克·福赛特和迈克尔·赫里迪，他们两个都没演过《神探阿蒙》。
I checked. Oh, good call to check though. Also, can we talk about how when the police first arrived, Creed stood up as if he was going to be handcuffed. And then put his hands behind his head. Yeah. And then he's talking head where he's like, just keep talking to me until the police leave. I love it.
I checked. Oh, good call to check though. Also, can we talk about how when the police first arrived, Creed stood up as if he was going to be handcuffed. And then put his hands behind his head. Yeah. And then he's talking head where he's like, just keep talking to me until the police leave. I love it.|||我查过了。不过查得好。还有，我们能聊聊当警察刚到时，克里德站起来的那个动作吗，就好像他要被戴上手铐一样。然后把双手抱在脑后。对。接着是他的单人访谈，他说，只要一直跟我说话，直到警察离开就行。我太喜欢了。
So good. I love it so much. We got some fan mail. Brooke else said that Toby seemed very concerned about police officers searching his desk. Could this be because they might find evidence of him being the Scranton Strangler? Oh, I don't know. At 16 minutes, 27 seconds, we have a very rare side by side talking head. So rare.
So good. I love it so much. We got some fan mail. Brooke else said that Toby seemed very concerned about police officers searching his desk. Could this be because they might find evidence of him being the Scranton Strangler? Oh, I don't know. At 16 minutes, 27 seconds, we have a very rare side by side talking head. So rare.|||太棒了。我太喜欢了。我们收到了粉丝来信。布鲁克说，托比似乎非常担心警察搜查他的办公桌。这会不会是因为他们可能会找到他是斯克兰顿绞杀魔的证据呢？哦，我不知道。在16分27秒时，我们有一个非常罕见的左右并排双人访谈。极其罕见。
How did they get through it? I don't know. Michael and Toby side by side. I know. I would have loved to have been a fly on a wall in that talking head because you know. I looked for the bloopers. I was like, surely, surely there's something on the blooper reel. I looked too.
How did they get through it? I don't know. Michael and Toby side by side. I know. I would have loved to have been a fly on a wall in that talking head because you know. I looked for the bloopers. I was like, surely, surely there's something on the blooper reel. I looked too.|||他们是怎么忍住不笑场拍完的？我不知道。迈克尔和托比并排坐着。我知道。我当时特别想做那个访谈现场墙上的一只苍蝇，因为你知道的。我找过幕后花絮。我想，肯定、绝对会有相关的NG镜头。我也找了。
Yes. Because I was like, I know these guys. I know Steve and Paul together and they were as tickled by the Toby-Michael relationship as the audience was, as we all were. Yes. And they would mess with each other. You remember in a scene, there's a blooper where Toby has to hand Michael a piece of paper and Steve and him start cracking up because Paul wrote, you want it?
Yes. Because I was like, I know these guys. I know Steve and Paul together and they were as tickled by the Toby-Michael relationship as the audience was, as we all were. Yes. And they would mess with each other. You remember in a scene, there's a blooper where Toby has to hand Michael a piece of paper and Steve and him start cracking up because Paul wrote, you want it?|||对。因为我想，我太了解这俩人了。我太了解史蒂夫和保罗凑在一起时的状态了，他们和观众以及我们所有人一样，对托比和迈克尔的关系乐此不疲。是的。而且他们总是互相捉弄对方。还记得有个场景的NG镜头吗，托比得递给迈克尔一张纸，结果史蒂夫和他俩突然大笑起来，因为保罗在纸上写着：“你想要吗？”
Yes. So I know they were giving it to each other and I wish there were some bloopers from this. There is footage somewhere for sure. Somewhere. Well, listen, in the annex, Ryan and Kelly are making out again. Oh, it's such a sloppy make out too. It is. Not that a tidy make out would have made it any better at work.
Yes. So I know they were giving it to each other and I wish there were some bloopers from this. There is footage somewhere for sure. Somewhere. Well, listen, in the annex, Ryan and Kelly are making out again. Oh, it's such a sloppy make out too. It is. Not that a tidy make out would have made it any better at work.|||没错。所以我知道他们一直在互开玩笑，我真希望有这部分的NG花絮。录像肯定在某个地方存着。某个地方。好了，听着，在小隔间里，瑞安和凯莉又在难舍难分地亲热了。哦，那吻得可真够黏糊的。确实。倒不是说在工作场所亲热得文雅点就能好到哪去。
Exactly. Well, Ryan wants out. He doesn't want a sloppy make out. He doesn't want a tidy one. He's going to Thailand with some friends from high school, a high school. You know, he has to break up with her because if he doesn't, he'll always resent her. If he didn't go, he would like them to be adults about it. Maybe they could have sex one more time.
Exactly. Well, Ryan wants out. He doesn't want a sloppy make out. He doesn't want a tidy one. He's going to Thailand with some friends from high school, a high school. You know, he has to break up with her because if he doesn't, he'll always resent her. If he didn't go, he would like them to be adults about it. Maybe they could have sex one more time.|||确实如此。好吧，瑞安想甩掉她。他既不想黏糊地亲热，也不想文雅地亲热。他要和几个高中同学去泰国旅游，高中同学。你知道的，他必须跟她分手，因为如果不分，他一辈子都会怨恨她。如果他不走的话……他希望他们能像成年人一样处理这件事。也许他们可以再做最后一次爱。
And does she have any cash? Let's be adults about it, but we could also have sex one more time. That's such a dude move. I feel like I've heard that so many times. I know. Do you want to have some goodbye sex? No. No.
And does she have any cash? Let's be adults about it, but we could also have sex one more time. That's such a dude move. I feel like I've heard that so many times. I know. Do you want to have some goodbye sex? No. No.|||她身上有现金吗？咱们成熟点对待这事，不过我们也可以再来一次。这绝对是渣男的标准操作。我觉得这句话我听过无数次了。我懂。你想来一次分手炮吗？不想。不想。
Goodbye. Get your sorry ass out of here. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. Fan question from Gracie are, when Ryan is telling Kelly he's going to Thailand, why are they both wearing different clothes? I'll tell you, Gracie, because this scene was originally supposed to be the tag at the end of the episode, and it was meant to be a new work day.
Goodbye. Get your sorry ass out of here. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. Fan question from Gracie are, when Ryan is telling Kelly he's going to Thailand, why are they both wearing different clothes? I'll tell you, Gracie, because this scene was originally supposed to be the tag at the end of the episode, and it was meant to be a new work day.|||再见。带着你那倒霉样滚开。对，没错。嗯。格蕾西的粉丝提问是：当瑞安告诉凯莉他要去泰国时，为什么他们俩穿的衣服不一样？我来告诉你，格蕾西，因为这个场景原本应该是这一集末尾的彩蛋，而且设定是在新的一工作日。
So in the script, this scene was not during the same day that we were framing Toby. It was the next day. But in editing, they moved it up, and we are going to end instead with a delicious Dwight talking head. We'll get to it. But first, Jim needs to show Pam what he's done. That's right. Jim is nervous, but excited.
So in the script, this scene was not during the same day that we were framing Toby. It was the next day. But in editing, they moved it up, and we are going to end instead with a delicious Dwight talking head. We'll get to it. But first, Jim needs to show Pam what he's done. That's right. Jim is nervous, but excited.|||所以在剧本里，这场戏并不是在我们陷害托比的那一天发生的。那是第二天。但在剪辑时，他们把这场戏提前了，最后我们用一段绝妙的德怀特单人访谈来收尾。我们待会儿会聊到。但首先，吉姆得让帕姆看看他干了什么。没错。吉姆很紧张，但也兴奋。
He is, as my daughter says, nervous-sided. She's like, why are we stopping at your parents' house? And he says, I bought it. And then Jenna, at 18 minutes, two seconds, Jim says, let's go inside. I'll show you inside. What? Has Pam never been inside the house? We got so much mail about that.
He is, as my daughter says, nervous-sided. She's like, why are we stopping at your parents' house? And he says, I bought it. And then Jenna, at 18 minutes, two seconds, Jim says, let's go inside. I'll show you inside. What? Has Pam never been inside the house? We got so much mail about that.|||正如我女儿所说，他这是“紧张并期待着”。她会问：我们为什么要在你父母家停下？然后他说：我把它买下来了。然后，珍娜，在18分零2秒时，吉姆说：我们进去吧。我带你进去看看。什么？帕姆从来没去过这栋房子里面吗？我们收到了大量关于这事的来信。
People wrote in. They said, if Pam knew they were at Jim's parents' house when they pulled up, wouldn't that mean she's been there before and she's probably been inside? You would hope Pam has been inside his parents' house. They've been dating for a while. They live in the same town. Yeah, and it's interesting because his parents have moved out, but they've left some furniture. Also, how rough were they on this house?
People wrote in. They said, if Pam knew they were at Jim's parents' house when they pulled up, wouldn't that mean she's been there before and she's probably been inside? You would hope Pam has been inside his parents' house. They've been dating for a while. They live in the same town. Yeah, and it's interesting because his parents have moved out, but they've left some furniture. Also, how rough were they on this house?|||观众写信说。他们说，如果帕姆车子开到时就知道那是吉姆父母的房子，那岂不是意味着她以前去过那儿，而且很可能进去过？你肯定希望帕姆去过他父母的房子里面。他们已经交往一段时间了。他们住在同一个小镇。对，很有意思的是，他父母虽然搬走了，但留了一些家具。还有，他们到底把这房子糟蹋成什么样了？
I know. And Jim says, I was helping my mom out. Where's his dad? I don't know. I have a lot of questions. There were a lot of questions. Rachel M. and Megan L. said, question for Jenna. In this episode, when Jim is showing Pam his parents' house, I was wondering what went
I know. And Jim says, I was helping my mom out. Where's his dad? I don't know. I have a lot of questions. There were a lot of questions. Rachel M. and Megan L. said, question for Jenna. In this episode, when Jim is showing Pam his parents' house, I was wondering what went|||我懂。而且吉姆说，我在帮我妈妈的忙。他爸爸呢？我不知道。我有一肚子疑问。确实有好多疑问。雷切尔·M和梅根·L问：有个问题想问珍娜。在这集中，当吉姆带帕姆参观他父母的房子时，我想知道你是如何决定去诠释这场戏的，因为她看起来真的很担心而且并不兴奋，但最后她却说她很喜欢。
in to how you decided to play this scene because she seems really worried and unexcited, but then in the end, she says she loves it. Any input you could give about how you decided to play this or what the director told you would be super appreciated. Well, guys, we've already discussed my personal opinions on someone buying someone else a house without telling them. So this was a little bit of a mental gymnastics for me. To get Pam to the place where she's going to say she loves it and where she says that
in to how you decided to play this scene because she seems really worried and unexcited, but then in the end, she says she loves it. Any input you could give about how you decided to play this or what the director told you would be super appreciated. Well, guys, we've already discussed my personal opinions on someone buying someone else a house without telling them. So this was a little bit of a mental gymnastics for me. To get Pam to the place where she's going to say she loves it and where she says that|||对于你决定如何演绎这一幕，或者导演跟你说了些什么，如果你能分享一点见解，我们将感激不尽。好吧，各位，我们之前已经讨论过我对于“在不告诉对方的情况下去给对方买栋房子”这一行为的个人看法。所以这对我来说有点心理体操。为了让帕姆达到那种会说“她很喜欢”的心理状态，并且说出那句
line, I mean, you bought me a house because it was not how I would react as Jenna. I had to really play the character and play the character's truth. And in the script, I was being told that my character's truth was that she loved this gesture and it made her feel loved. Yeah. Well, I mean, I think we often did that. Obviously, we had to play the truth for the character. I mean, I hope you guys know I'm not very much like Angela Martin and how I would react
line, I mean, you bought me a house because it was not how I would react as Jenna. I had to really play the character and play the character's truth. And in the script, I was being told that my character's truth was that she loved this gesture and it made her feel loved. Yeah. Well, I mean, I think we often did that. Obviously, we had to play the truth for the character. I mean, I hope you guys know I'm not very much like Angela Martin and how I would react|||台词——“天哪，你给我买了一栋房子”——因为如果换作是珍娜，我的反应绝不会是这样。我必须真正代入角色，并展现出角色的真实内心。剧本告诉我的角色真实内心是，她喜欢这个举动，这让她感到了被爱。是的。好吧，我的意思是，我觉得我们经常这么做。显然，我们必须展现角色的真实感受。我是说，希望大家知道，在面对事情的反应上，我可一点都不像安琪拉·马丁，
to things, but it made sense to me, Jenna, for Pam, you know, and Jim made the garage into this art studio and he's really putting down some roots with her. And I think Pam wanted a family and she wanted all of these things that Jim is offering her. She had wanted that. Yeah. So I had thought a little bit back on the talking head where Pam discusses what her perfect home would look like, how she always wanted a home with a terrace, you know, picking her home seemed like something that Pam was attached to.
to things, but it made sense to me, Jenna, for Pam, you know, and Jim made the garage into this art studio and he's really putting down some roots with her. And I think Pam wanted a family and she wanted all of these things that Jim is offering her. She had wanted that. Yeah. So I had thought a little bit back on the talking head where Pam discusses what her perfect home would look like, how she always wanted a home with a terrace, you know, picking her home seemed like something that Pam was attached to.|||但对我珍娜来说，这对于帕姆是说得通的，你知道的，吉姆把车库改造成了这个艺术工作室，他真的在和她一起扎根生活。而且我认为帕姆渴望建立一个家庭，渴望得到吉姆提供给她的这一切。她一直都渴望这些。是的。所以我稍微回想了一下帕姆在单人访谈中讨论她理想中的家是什么样子的那一幕，她一直想要一个带露台的家，你知道的，挑选自己的家似乎是帕姆一直很执着的一件事。
So I did bring that up. I said, you know, we've established that Pam has daydreamed about what her home would look like and now this person has taken her out of the process. You brought that up to the writers at the time of when we were filming. Yeah. And so I was saying like, help me understand why Pam now is so happy and so excited. And Angela, we got to exactly what you just said, which was that it was a vulnerable thing for Pam to give up the art school track.
So I did bring that up. I said, you know, we've established that Pam has daydreamed about what her home would look like and now this person has taken her out of the process. You brought that up to the writers at the time of when we were filming. Yeah. And so I was saying like, help me understand why Pam now is so happy and so excited. And Angela, we got to exactly what you just said, which was that it was a vulnerable thing for Pam to give up the art school track.|||所以我确实把这一点提了出来。我说，你知道的，我们之前已经设定过帕姆曾幻想过自己的家是什么样子的，而现在这个人却把她排除在了这个过程之外。你在我们拍摄的时候把这个向编剧提出来了。是的。所以我当时在说，帮我理解一下为什么帕姆现在会这么高兴、这么兴奋。安琪拉，我们讨论得出的结论正好就是你刚才所说的，那就是帕姆放弃艺术学校的道路是一件很脆弱、需要极大勇气的事。
And she did that because of two reasons. One, graphic design wasn't what she meant she wanted to do as an artist. And two, she's ready. She's very, very ready to start living this married life, to be in the season of family and marriage with this man that she's been waiting years for. And so this home is her fast track to that season of her life and she's just ready. Yeah. And you know, they're going to get to fix it up together.
And she did that because of two reasons. One, graphic design wasn't what she meant she wanted to do as an artist. And two, she's ready. She's very, very ready to start living this married life, to be in the season of family and marriage with this man that she's been waiting years for. And so this home is her fast track to that season of her life and she's just ready. Yeah. And you know, they're going to get to fix it up together.|||她这么做是因为两个原因。第一，平面设计并不是她作为艺术家真正想做的事。第二，她准备好了。她非常、非常准备好开始这种婚姻生活了，准备好和这个她等了多年的男人一起迈入家庭和婚姻的阶段。所以这个家就是她通往人生那个阶段的快车道，她已经准备好了。是的。而且你知道，他们以后可以一起把房子修缮好。
So there's still that element of nesting that's going to get to happen. And so that's kind of what I was thinking was like, I'm ready. Yeah. And you have to think when Pam talked about her dream house with this tower and the terrace and all of that, she was in an unhappy relationship. When you're in a place you feel stuck in life or you're unhappy, you daydream and you daydream about these fantastical things and they're coping mechanisms. And then when you're with someone you really love, you don't need the fantasy anymore.
So there's still that element of nesting that's going to get to happen. And so that's kind of what I was thinking was like, I'm ready. Yeah. And you have to think when Pam talked about her dream house with this tower and the terrace and all of that, she was in an unhappy relationship. When you're in a place you feel stuck in life or you're unhappy, you daydream and you daydream about these fantastical things and they're coping mechanisms. And then when you're with someone you really love, you don't need the fantasy anymore.|||所以那种“筑巢”的元素依然会发生。这就是我当时的真实想法：我已经准备好了。是的。而且你得想想，当帕姆谈论她那带有塔楼和露台的梦想之屋时，她正身处于一段不幸福的恋爱关系中。当你处于一个让你觉得生活停滞不前或不快乐的境地时，你就会白日做梦，幻想这些异想天开的事情，这是一种应对机制。然后，当你和一个真正爱的人在一起时，你就不再需要这种幻想了。
That's such a good point, Angela. You're just ready to have a life. And she's ready to have that life. Yeah. Now we did get some mail about that garage. Katie C. and Chris G said, when Jim is showing Pam his parents' house, he says the garage has great lighting. He then proceeds to open a windowless garage door revealing a completely windowless garage
That's such a good point, Angela. You're just ready to have a life. And she's ready to have that life. Yeah. Now we did get some mail about that garage. Katie C. and Chris G said, when Jim is showing Pam his parents' house, he says the garage has great lighting. He then proceeds to open a windowless garage door revealing a completely windowless garage|||安琪拉，这观点太精辟了。你只是准备好去过一种真正的生活了。而她也准备好过那种生活了。是的。话说我们确实收到了一些关于那个车库的来信。凯蒂·C和克里斯·G说：当吉姆带帕姆参观他父母的房子时，他说车库采光极好。接着他去打开了一扇没有窗户的车库门，露出了一个完全没有窗户的车库空间。
space. Where's the great lighting, Jim? Where? Okay, well, I thought that was really funny. That is really funny. I want you guys to know that I have a garage that we use as a home office. And for a long time, we would just raise the door. And then there would be amazing light.
space. Where's the great lighting, Jim? Where? Okay, well, I thought that was really funny. That is really funny. I want you guys to know that I have a garage that we use as a home office. And for a long time, we would just raise the door. And then there would be amazing light.|||采光好在哪儿呢，吉姆？在哪儿呢？好吧，我当时觉得这真的太好笑了。确实超级好笑。我想让大家知道的是，我家里有一个车库，我们把它当成了家庭办公室。在很长一段时间里，我们都只是把卷帘门拉起来。然后就会有超棒的光线。
You know? Yeah. So it did get great light, but you had to raise the door. And then years later, we actually just removed the door because we're like, this is never going to be a garage again. You know, we've sort of made it into this little home office and put an actual sliding glass door. But I get it.
You know? Yeah. So it did get great light, but you had to raise the door. And then years later, we actually just removed the door because we're like, this is never going to be a garage again. You know, we've sort of made it into this little home office and put an actual sliding glass door. But I get it.|||你知道吗？对的。所以它的确采光很好，但你得把门拉起来。然后几年后，我们干脆把门给拆了，因为我们觉得：这地方以后绝不可能再当车库用了。你知道的，我们把它改造成了这个小小的家庭办公室，并安了一扇真正的玻璃移门。不过我懂。
It does have great lighting. You just have to open it up. But he does present it like this garage has great lighting as if the other garages that you open the whole side of the building wouldn't have great lighting. He's presenting as if it's like a special feature that kind of applies to every garage that doesn't have like a giant tree planted in front of it, which it wouldn't because it's a garage. Right.
It does have great lighting. You just have to open it up. But he does present it like this garage has great lighting as if the other garages that you open the whole side of the building wouldn't have great lighting. He's presenting as if it's like a special feature that kind of applies to every garage that doesn't have like a giant tree planted in front of it, which it wouldn't because it's a garage. Right.|||它的采光确实很好。你只要把它打开就行。但他介绍时的语气，好像这个车库的采光独一无二似的，就好像其他那种只要一打开就能敞开整面墙的车库采光会不好一样。他的介绍听起来就像这是个特殊功能，仿佛适用于任何前面没有种参天大树的车库——而车库前面本来就不会有大树。没错。
Most garages are just boxes with no windows. I have to tell you two things about shooting these scenes at the house. The scene where Jim is trying to take the clown painting off the wall for Pam is one of the hardest I've ever laughed on the show. It is the second hardest time. The first was when we did the scene in dinner party where Michael's showing us the tiny TV on the wall. This is the second.
Most garages are just boxes with no windows. I have to tell you two things about shooting these scenes at the house. The scene where Jim is trying to take the clown painting off the wall for Pam is one of the hardest I've ever laughed on the show. It is the second hardest time. The first was when we did the scene in dinner party where Michael's showing us the tiny TV on the wall. This is the second.|||大多数车库都只是没有窗户的方盒子。关于在房子里拍摄这些场景，我有两件事必须告诉你们。吉姆试图为帕姆把墙上的小丑画取下来的那一幕，是我在整部剧拍摄过程中笑得最厉害的一次。这是我笑得第二惨的一次。第一次是我们在拍《晚宴派对》那一集时，迈克尔向我们展示墙上那个微型电视机的场景。这是第二惨。
Every time John tried to lift the painting on the wall, I could not stop laughing. I don't know what it was, tears, tears choking on our laughter. We laughed so hard. I looked forward in the bloopers and it's not there and I'm so upset it's not there. It took us like an hour to shoot that tiny moment of him trying to take the painting off the wall. John is also so funny at physical comedy. Yes.
Every time John tried to lift the painting on the wall, I could not stop laughing. I don't know what it was, tears, tears choking on our laughter. We laughed so hard. I looked forward in the bloopers and it's not there and I'm so upset it's not there. It took us like an hour to shoot that tiny moment of him trying to take the painting off the wall. John is also so funny at physical comedy. Yes.|||每次约翰试图把墙上的画抬起来时，我都笑得停不下来。我不知道是怎么回事，眼泪鼻涕横流，笑得喘不过气来。我们笑得太厉害了。我在NG花絮里找过这一段，结果里面没有，这让我非常沮丧。我们为了拍摄他试图把画取下来的那个小片段，花了大约一个小时。约翰在形体喜剧方面也太有喜感了。没错。
I laughed out loud when he peeled back that fake wood paneling and it kind of startled him. Yes. So then at the end of the scene in the garage, when we're hugging, I improvised the line, what about the clown? And it made John laugh and that's why he's like burying his head into my neck. And then when he said, yeah, I can't do anything about that, it made me laugh. And so I'm like smushing my face into his shoulder.
I laughed out loud when he peeled back that fake wood paneling and it kind of startled him. Yes. So then at the end of the scene in the garage, when we're hugging, I improvised the line, what about the clown? And it made John laugh and that's why he's like burying his head into my neck. And then when he said, yeah, I can't do anything about that, it made me laugh. And so I'm like smushing my face into his shoulder.|||当他剥开那层假木质护墙板并被吓了一跳时，我直接笑出了声。没错。所以在车库那场戏的结尾，当我们拥抱时，我即兴加了一句台词：“那小丑怎么办？”这把约翰逗笑了，这就是为什么他把头埋在我的脖子里。接着当他说：“是啊，我对那个无能为力”时，又把我逗笑了。所以我把脸整个埋在了他的肩膀上。
You can totally tell we're breaking. And that's why it was because we were still, anytime we brought up the clown painting, we lost it. I love that moment. It made it intimate and funny and sweet. I think it's time to talk about the greatest white talking head of all time. Not saying a lot because there are some amazing white talking heads, but this one really is like top five.
You can totally tell we're breaking. And that's why it was because we were still, anytime we brought up the clown painting, we lost it. I love that moment. It made it intimate and funny and sweet. I think it's time to talk about the greatest white talking head of all time. Not saying a lot because there are some amazing white talking heads, but this one really is like top five.|||你绝对能看出我们在笑场。这就是原因所在，因为只要我们一提起小丑画，我们就会彻底破功。我太喜欢那个时刻了。它让那个场面变得亲密、搞笑又甜蜜。我想是时候聊聊史上最棒的德怀特单人访谈了。虽然不能把话说太满，因为有太多精彩的德怀特访谈了，但这一段绝对能进前五。
He's going to describe his perfect crime and I think we have to hear it. What is my perfect crime? I break into Tiffany's in midnight. Do I go for the vault? No. I go for the chandelier. It's priceless. As I'm taking it down, a woman catches me.
他要描述他完美的犯罪，我觉得我们必须听听。我完美的犯罪是什么？我在午夜闯入蒂芙尼公司。我会去拿保险库吗？不。我去拿那个枝形吊灯。那是无价的。当我把它取下来时，一个女人抓住了我。
She tells me to stop. It's her father's business. She's Tiffany. I say no. We make love all night. In the morning, the cops come and I escape in one of their uniforms. I tell her to meet me in Mexico, but I go to Canada. I don't trust her.
她叫我住手。这是她父亲的生意。她就是蒂芙尼。我说不。我们整晚做爱。到了早上，警察来了，我穿着他们的制服逃跑了。我叫她在墨西哥见我，但我去了加拿大。我不信任她。
Besides, I like the cold. Thirty years later, I get a postcard. I have a son and he's the chief of police. This is where the story gets interesting. I tell Tiffany to meet me in Paris by the Trocadero. She's been waiting for me all these years. She's never taken another lover. I don't care.
况且，我喜欢寒冷。三十年后，我收到一张明信片。我有一个儿子，他是警察局长。故事从这里开始变得有趣。我告诉蒂芙尼在巴黎的特罗卡德罗广场见我。这么多年来她一直在等我。她从来没有找过别的爱人。我不在乎。
I don't show up. I go to Berlin. That's where I stash the chandelier. Yeah. I do not know how Rain got through saying, this is where the story gets interesting. I know. Every time I watched this episode, I laughed at that line and I watched it like three times. This entire talking head was scripted and it was delivered as scripted.
我没有出现。我去了柏林。那是我就藏枝形吊灯的地方。是的。我不知道雷恩是怎么把“故事从这里开始变得有趣”这句话说出口的。我知道。每次我看这一集，我都会那句台词笑出来，而且我看了大概三遍。整个访谈片段都是按剧本拍的，而且完全是按剧本发挥的。
I think this is one of the most brilliantly written pieces ever. It's just so good. It's so good and who better to deliver it than Rainn Wilson as Dwight? It was just perfect. I agree. There you have it, everyone. That's Framed Toby. Did you have anything else, Angela?
我认为这是写得最精彩的作品之一。真是太棒了。太棒了，由雷恩·威尔森饰演的德怀特来诠释还有谁比他更合适？简直完美。我同意。大家听到了吧。这就是陷害托比。安吉拉，你还有什么要说的吗？
I don't have anything else. I do want you guys to know because Jen and I both watched the bloopers. Next week on The Surplus was one of the hardest I've ever laughed in a scene. Oh, I can't wait. Thank you so much to Randy Cordray, James Carey, and Jen Salad and Paul Lieberstein. I traded some emails with them as well. Man, that was fun. That was a delight.
我没什么要说的了。我想让你们知道，因为珍和我两人都看了花絮。下周的《剩余资金》是我在一场戏里笑得最厉害的一次之一。哦，我等不及了。非常感谢兰迪·科德雷、詹姆斯·凯里、珍·萨拉德和保罗·利伯斯坦。我也和他们交换了一些电子邮件。天哪，太有趣了。真是一场视听盛宴。
I will be trying to clean my microwave using your method. Thank you. And we'll see you here next week. I'll be back in LA next week. I wonder, will I bring New York Jenna home with me? We'll see. I don't know. New York Jenna might get the E next to our podcast.
我会试着用你的方法清洗我的微波炉。谢谢。我们下周在这里见。我下周将回到洛杉矶。我在想，我会把“纽约珍娜”带回家吗？走着瞧吧。我不知道。纽约珍娜可能会给我们的播客带来一个E级评级。
Sorry. What can I say? See you next week, guys. See you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins.
对不起。我能说什么呢？大家下周见。下周见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利联合制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。
Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of StitcherPremium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，助理制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。要收听《办公室女士》的无广告版本，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用StitcherPremium一个月，请使用代码 OFFICE。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。